Gero going experience
[inaudible]
what?
What bitches we hear?
Yeah. Brian [inaudible]. Lisa gentlemen,
the one and only here. Good to be here.
Very excited when my favorite favorite
fucking human beings to ever walk the
face of the planet.
Thank you sir.
Can these here to join us at the
fucking birth of the apocalypse as it's
happening right before our eyes Steve,
build your canoes.
What the fuck is going on
man? I'm building canoes. I
live in Venice Bro. So I'm,
I'm, I'm going to, I got to have a canoe
on, on the top of my roof there. Oh,
you really thinking about
getting something like
that. I don't know if I can,
who's going to save you buddy? Come
out, all that stuff. You should.
I'm always thinking real worst case
scenarios, but you live by the water.
When you live by Venice,
you,
you really must take into account that
we just like Japan or on a fault line and
that should could happen here. That's
a fucking nine dude. A nine a nine.
We can't even wrap our heads
around what that means.
A nine is so video and I couldn't
believe how long it lasted.
Five minutes. Five minutes. That's
ridiculous. Five minutes at nine.
What would people, if people don't
know the Richter scale, how it works?
Every one point is 100% stronger
than the point before it. Right?
So 7.2 100% stronger than a 7.1.
This was a not so crazy.
This is the only that no human
beings have ever that are alive.
Have ever experienced that
before in recorded history? No,
not the biggest in recorded history with
the biggest that I think anybody that's
alive as ever experienced.
I believe it's the biggest Japan,
it guess it's the fifth or sixth biggest
earthquake in history and it's big.
The biggest one. Japan's
ever, I don't trust all that.
What happened were you doing with
divine sweaty. Okay. And when did you,
do you just change the volume side?
Is that better? Yeah. What'd you do?
I just turned down the is too high.
You know, I turned on the, Hey Joe,
I turned on the headphone volume cause
it's super loud in my headphones and the
only way I can uh, turn
down my headphones, it's
by turned on in your life.
Look at him. He's denying trying
to keep it like, oh, all right.
You got a little tense really quick
quickly to knows how to he got I think I'm
sure. I'm sure. I think
I'm serving right now.
Just keep it together but everything's
fine. Just don't freak out.
Don't freak out. Brian said that the
most important thing to these things,
just let it happen to just go with it
buddy. By the way, have you shrimp lately?
It's been a few months.
I haven't served in like eight years
because the last time I shermed I have
violently was shitting and puking at the
same time and tripping in the bathroom
for like
six hours.
It was a horrible experience so I have
been kind of nervous to do it again.
Eight on the last night, most beautiful
thing in the whole entire road.
Like amazing.
There was parts I was with my friend
where I was looking at them and like their
faces, you could just feel the energy
coming from their face like visually.
It was amazing.
How much did you only ate half of eighth
and made it into a tea and did the ti
process where you,
you boil it and then,
and then you drink it and then he let
let sit for like another whatever,
30 minutes or whatever. And then you
ate those shrooms and it was awesome.
Why should I drink the tea?
And you chose so clean.
Ever tell you my shrimp
mushrooms experienced with
the last time I did shrooms
cause I was never a seasoned drug addict.
I was with Patty Murray. Patty. Sure.
So I take mushrooms and I eat a
lot of them cause man, I was like,
let me see what these
are like a cut to me.
I took a four hour shower and had,
I wept,
I laughed,
I reassessed my life and then I saw,
started seeing myself from the side.
I just started seeing my profile and I
was sitting on a wall looking down at me.
You know my profile and I was like,
here's a couple of problems.
My legs way too short for my torso.
Oh by the way,
I'm a coat hanger. I've always
wanted to be a barrel chested Samoan.
I'm on a coat hanger
from a long line peasant,
an Irish stock who are used to
being persecuted, running, you know,
knobby knees. The whole thing
was a disaster. Genetics
are enough. Fair now man.
You look at some fucking football players,
some of those giant Goliath.
You could get a guy like check Congo,
like when you're standing next to
check Congo genetics and welfare.
There's dudes that are born like your
friend that we were talking about in the
kitchen. Your friend of your
doughy small, the feminist friend.
That guy just got to roll the dice.
It looks like an overgrown baby.
It's just a roll of the dice. Man.
He could've been checked Congo.
I know what the fuck.
I know I can be built to like any,
if I could have any jeans in the,
I'd want Samoan. Some Simone,
just big and they can take a punch to,
she's as Christ Mark Hunt.
He's a k one champion and he's now when
he's fighting in the UFC now he just won
his last fight and uh,
he's famous for it.
Dude's head kicking him and he just
fucking wobbles a little and then
straightens right back up. Loans come in,
they did a thing on, if you are Samoan,
you are 55 times.
I believe this was the number and it was
on 60 minutes and I believe they said
you're,
if you're Simone,
you are 55 times more
likely to play in the NFL.
Any white guy on the planet.
There's so there's still fucking
strong Hong Gins that Lowery's and the,
and the Samoans. This just on
another giant bones like your wrists,
like elbows and fast,
like a lot of fast twitch muscle,
not this endurance muscle like,
oh yeah, it could have been like,
I knew his trainer dude,
he was so bad ass, but for
whatever reason, never really,
totally got it together.
Lennox Lewis beat them and that
took a lot of wind out of his sails.
Cause when it's tagged him a
couple times pretty hard. Well,
I know the guy that trained, uh, to
have for that fight for
the Lennox Lewis fight.
I've actually worked out with him and
he said that the first time I'd had ever
done, he never done a squat and I
believe, I don't want to misquote him,
but he didn't. He said he put four 20 on
his shoulders and he did a deep squat.
He went all the way down to where his
ass touching his heels and came back up
and the trainer was like, who
is a power lifter? It was like,
that's the craziest thing I've ever
seen in my life. You've never squatted.
He goes, no man. By the end of it, he
was like, they had that has two horses,
two dead horses to a bar. You know, he's,
he's one of the scariest heavyweight
boxers would come along in a long time.
He wasn't able to beat the best guys
that you never beat Lennox Lewis,
but he could,
he could put anybody to sleep.
Do you ever see the fight when he
fought John Ruiz? No. He caught John.
It's on youtube. He caught genre
is a very big man. Tough dude too.
You know he's a burly guy.
Didn't John Ridley's fight Holyfield
like three fucking times. Yeah,
I think he did. He was, he was rough
David too. We'll put them to sleep.
Dude just jumped on him early.
Hit him with those gigantic ham hocks.
Fix it. Hit him with like he tagged
them early and then just put them away.
Put them completely to sleep.
You know,
you wonder as more and more
money ventures in the MMA a lot.
Some of those guys who are playing
some of those Hershel Walker's and and,
and Michael Vick's, they're going
to start coming to MMA. Yeah.
Some of the guys who don't want
to, they don't want to, you know,
be playing for a team. They'd rather
fight footballs. Also ironically,
way more dangerous for you
then is any MMA career.
That's so funny that people dispute that,
but everyone looks at
it in an emotional way.
You don't look at it in a contact way.
Like look at these people are running
at each other and at 50 years old,
take a look at their heads.
I mean, it's not even,
it's not a little bit more dangerous.
It's way more way more dangers.
US fucking poor guys. Like that
kid was his name, Chris Henry,
the kid that fell off the back
of a pickup truck and died.
You remember he was a chasing after
his girlfriend. Receiver. Yeah. Yeah.
Really talented athlete.
Right. Well young kid I built,
I think he was only like 25, 25
or 20, I think it was 25. Anyway,
it's fucking massive brain
damage. When they went, did
an autopsy on him, you know,
the concussions and he's hands,
he's playing football actually shrinks
and all Kinda, you get dementia.
I mean that's what Lou
Gehrig's disease is all about.
I mean a lot of these guys are getting it.
It's all from head impacts
and just reparable damage.
Yeah. Cause it als or
Lou Gehrig's disease, um,
they used to think was a
function of toxin, a toxin.
They had all different kinds of theories,
but they're, they're starting to link,
they think they're starting to link
some of this stuff to the als syndrome,
whatever, to um, to, uh, um, yeah,
there was a whole Bryant Gumbel special
about it. It's scary stuff, man.
People take that real lightly, you know,
they take head trauma real lightly.
We don't, we're learning more and
more, I guess now and now, you know,
that really raises a huge question,
which is if,
if indeed you can start to prove that
for concussions or three concussions
caused brain damage, if
that's the case or, and, and
the, and if they're able
to actually measure this,
it will put a real onus on the NFL to
figure out a way to either change the
rules or make helmet safer, but then you
don't have football. Right. You know,
so it really,
it kind of,
it doesn't raise rugby's probably
safer because they don't wear helmets.
They tell me don't smash each other.
I went to a rugby match recently
actually in the south of France with a,
I think it was like the bask team with
the aim of trying to do now and even
international traveler.
I done an international sports
events to soccer and phones.
I seller in the south of tribes.
Of course. Yes. And, and uh,
I wish I could speak that way.
How would it be that, that,
that really pretentious man, you
know, compared to a lot of people,
what you just said was that,
yeah,
I didn't even me I'm talking about I go
to a soccer game and France like what?
Two things I don't need
plugged in tight shorts.
Thing I noticed was that there that
they're just as, they're a huge men,
a lot of Samoans, just huge dudes.
Shrug the players. Starts by the way,
really overseeing that thing that
they do that and know that dance,
they dance at the Haka.
Holy Shit Dude.
That's the New Zealand all blacks.
It's my favorite thing.
Did you see ever see
the black and white one?
There's a black and white one of them.
I've seen every one of them more than
it does to me. It's like an Adidas had,
is that what it is? Fuck. It's good.
Have you ever seen that? If go go,
if you're listening to this, go
to do a Haka dance, New Zealand,
all blacks and, and there are so many
of them, and take a look at that day.
It's a war dance and they'd been
doing it since the 18 hundreds, uh,
and it's carried on as a tradition
and they take it seriously. Dope.
It would think it's stupid.
Like, what is this dumb ass shit?
I got a really good one for. You can
see this one too. Freaks. He's just,
he just literally just
freaks they, they've worked
themselves into a frenzy, man.
Yeah, it's a, it's a fascinating thing to
watch. It's fun. It looks like it's real.
You know what I mean?
Like they're going crazy,
but it's not like I don't
feel like you're faking it.
I feel like that's what they're thinking.
That's in their heart.
I believe him and Jimmy,
Jimmy Burke, by the way,
our dear friend Jimmy Burke from New York,
I got in a fight and my friend got in a
fight with a guy cause he told the guy,
he looked like a combination of Rudolph
Nureyev and uh, uh, he was this big guy,
walks out and goes, he was drunk. Goes
Dude, you look like Rudolph Nureyev and,
and some other old actor and
something that like, you know,
I don't know like Clark Gable or,
and the guy's like,
why did it goes and then he comes
back and he goes, what'd you say?
I look like it goes Uday up cause
he, cause he has, he walked out,
he goes, he had rid of Nerd, he was a gay
dance or gay dance. I think that means,
but anyway, and the guy
goes, what looks back?
And he comes back and he goes, what would
you say? I look like that's gay woo woo.
Anyway, the guy takes his, Jack
goes, let's go outside right now.
So chimney goes out there and my buddy
juries with them and he and he says to
Jerry, whispers to everything I do. It's
like January. He takes his shirt off,
he's got no shirt on, it's freezing. He
starts doing the Haka dance at the dude,
but he's not looking at the guy
and the guy starts to flip in.
The bounces are holding them back
and Jimmy never looked at it.
We just did the Haka dance but made a
really sexual sexual Haka dance and he was
like, Hey, Hey da, and he's not looking
at him and flexing basically posing.
You have to explain this Guy Jimmy
Burke for this story to really work.
You tell us about a normal person
and you're going to be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That doesn't even,
I can't even make sense out of that.
Like did someone would judge me.
Burke is 50 years old. He's ease.
We call them the national treasure.
He's got a very long neck.
He's got very red skin.
He's got no eyebrows and very,
very one of my favorite fucking
Jimmy Burke lines ever. He goes,
I ran into her accidentally. She
thought I was stalking her. She goes,
he's talking to me. I'm like,
believe me, honey, if I,
if I was stalking you wouldn't be
caught me and I have stalked her
and I have stock. That was a
good fucking funny, that guy.
Funniest, craziest. I got it for
the impression at the beginning,
but then I lost it. I need to be around
him more. I need to see that guy.
I'm going to be in New York.
He's battery,
very enthusiastic.
He really moves his mouth and by the way,
by the way, he's a very good shape.
Very good. You know, they hold it,
hold. That map was in very good shape and
weight. If you're reacting, you're like,
oh, he does. He does.
He makes children cry
because he loves kids.
He's like, Woo. And sure enough,
shining babies, like four year
olds are like, he's like, he,
and then he looked at me one time,
he went down to the baby and I was
laying and he's going, oh sure it off.
I'm like, one, two, three.
It takes three seconds.
He pulled the slide.
I look like skeletor.
It looked like a red scout and he
looks at the mother. He goes, he goes,
I'm so sorry. And his face looks
like it's plasticine. What?
He says that if you know him, it doesn't
make you uncomfortable. But if God,
if I did know him and there was
a guy like that, I'd be like,
what does this loose cannon?
I can't predict what he might do.
I might do something nutty. He
did this. How about this? He,
I'm saying this a podcast. I hope he's
listening. I literally, um, he, he,
first of all, he, he rides
his bike everywhere. He,
he's 50 on a bicycle on a TV and that's
all he said. And that's all he wants.
He's like, how he's always been, he's a
monk. He's a true monk. And uh, and he,
and he's in better shape than anybody
in the world. He says, come downstairs.
I'm on 57th and eighth and ninth,
and my mother's apartment. He goes,
it's literally 12 at night in New York
City on like Christmas Eve or around
Christmas, you know, where everybody's
on the street, you know, it's everyone.
And he goes, come downstairs.
I have to show you something.
Come down in five minutes, click. I
go, all right, this should be good.
Throwing my coat. I got off stage.
I'm standing with the doorman outside.
I hear from a long, long way
away. Ah, um, um, uh, uh,
a tape deck, the halls with
balls up, holiday. [inaudible]
and he's rides by me
and I in a down jacket,
cowboy hat and no pants,
no pants.
And he's writing, he's popping with
his ass in the air. And I see this,
this dead baby bird, this,
this, this, and this. This pad,
what it looked like, a large
boy. Just say, you know, he's
gonna, he's home, but he's,
it's just the no heroin. He's got a little
red hairs on it and it's a disaster.
The whole thing. And this white body,
he sees me on white neon, like Irish,
like though, like lost the picnic. I'm
like Gollum, loss of pigment lottery.
He gets into his son, he starts smoking
literally. He was like a vampire,
I swear to God. So he's
got this incredible, and he
just, and this woman goes,
he's coming this way. He's
coming in sweat. He goes,
Chris Smith's man.
And literally I just see he bikes by
in his ass and I see his two balls,
his 50 year old balls just just swinging
like a pendulum outside. And she,
the woman goes, he's coming this way.
He's coming this way. He, she goes,
she goes and screams at him and he goes,
have a great time.
It turns back around and try us
back a block near to Jesus Christ.
He is a streaker man.
What is he doing for living in these days?
He still acts and you know, he
said he does. He does. Funny.
He's got really rich friends too who
all want him around. So please come,
come on the trip. It's a private jet.
We'll take anywhere. He's like, all right.
That's the thing about Joe.
He heals very few people in the world,
especially when they get there. And
I can do this, can be like, dude,
you want to go to a Tibet, Tibet,
alright, no plans, nothing,
nothing, nothing. And what does
it do? Just cause clients, hey,
I'm not going to train you this week
or not or not. He just goes to Tibet.
It doesn't say anything to that. And
then they show up at their appointments.
What's his dad? So he goes all over the
world for free. He's such an odd duck man.
This, I've always admired how, how,
what, what a free spirit he is.
But also like how like you always
think like guys like that are going to,
you know,
some point in time at least make an
attempt to appear to have their shit
together. No, he knows.
He's an amazing guy.
And I'm going to tell you
the other thing he is,
is he's truly made peace with like with
his true atheists, like a real atheist,
truly made peace with the fact that he
is only here for a short period of time
and he's, he's dying to him is
not something he's afraid of.
He came down with tuberculosis,
but they didn't know what it was
cause he had been exposed to it by his
grandfather when he was
three years old. Oh, he's,
he starts going to the hospital and they,
I get a call,
my buddy says they're looking at it,
they think as lung cancer or
that disease that those nine one,
one firemen get that where your
lungs disintegrate from breathing,
all that stuff. I have the
one, they're both fail. So,
and they're looking for it and they tell
them, look, this is probably what it is.
And I was with him when it was shortly
after he knew all that you would never
have known and it's not
denial. He said to me, he goes,
he told me what the prognosis was. And
I was like, Jesus, my best friends.
I was like, this is the worst thing.
And he said, I said, how do you feel?
You seem so normally. He goes,
Brian, first of all, if I'm
going to die, I'm going to treat it
like it's a comedy. And Oh, by the way,
my funeral better be a good time and
you better make people laugh. Oh.
And by the way, I've made peace
with my life. I'm not afraid to die.
And I saw that firsthand, which
I thought it was just, you know,
he's just an amazing guy. He's got a good
grip on things in a weird way, you know,
he reads everything. He knows
that. I mean, he knows so
much. Very, very bright guy.
That's why it's,
it's so strange that guys like that
almost always in somehow or another they
fall into some, at least a semblance of
normalcy. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like they don't, they're not 50 with an
apartment and a TV and a bike, you know,
like you try to get your shit together,
you try it, you run a house somewhere.
Yeah. Yeah. We've got a house now looking
to buy, but you know, anywhere which he,
he, he never, he never
was. He's never been.
And it's not like anything is
self conscious about either? No.
Is this guy ticketless? Uh, I don't know.
Let's find out. Brian. I don't know.
Brian got some time this weekend and
just see what Gilbert Godfrey said, uh,
about Japan. Yeah. What do
you, what do you guys think
about that? Have you seen it?
Well, let's read the quotes,
the quotes Gilbert got, right.
Yeah. To me it was like, all
right, that's, that's not
even trying to be like, ah,
edgy or like, I don't know what he's
thinking. He's pretty funny. Yeah. I mean,
but still, I don't even think that's even
to me. Yeah. Too soon. What did you think?
What did you think of?
I was so,
I just thought definitely does he realize
how many people died and how many kids
died? How many fucking,
you know, seriously,
if there's time where you should just
not do anything and there's definitely,
I think a time period,
you know?
Wow. Yeah. I don't, I don't
try to stay anything like that.
I mean,
that's what it felt.
I'm not fucking raising
flags and protesting and
anytime that's fair to to be
con, I think we should all be more
conscious of people's feelings.
It's 50 cents a 50 censored a look.
This is very serious people.
I had to evacuate all my hoes from La,
Hawaii and Japan.
I had to do it. Lol. He gets points
up until the lol. That's right.
First of all, because lol, lol.
Especially when you have the,
just the first letter capitalized
and then the next one,
not that looks really fucking stupid
dog. Alright, that looks dumb.
Either you go with all caps or no caps
with your lol. Okay. Second of all,
are you a girl? No. Then
what's with the lol? Listen,
that's for girls and retards.
That's what lol is for or,
but the, the idea behind it, you know,
that you just started immediately making
jokes about all these poor fucking
people they're going to hit
next and that kind of stuff.
I don't have a problem with people making
jokes about it. Why wait? You know,
I don't know. I think what he said was
hilarious. I had evacuated all my hoes.
I mean, come on. That's fucking
funny. Since one was fine
with me. What, what did, uh,
coffee, sir. Okay. You had a much
more Gilbert Godfrey. Let's see.
Let's see what his tweet said.
Gilbert Godfrey's tweets where uh, oh,
the not even shown them, man.
They covered him up. Well,
it's not in this one. One
way go. Our stories, whether
or not one was kind of like,
hey, my girlfriend broke up with me, don't
worry. Another one will float by soon,
or something like that. I
can't find them. Unfortunately.
I think some asking, you're trying to be
funny. Sometimes things can go awry. Yeah,
well, I mean he's just a silly guy.
You know, he's a silly guy who,
who's funny and then,
yeah,
but that's something you say to your
friends maybe a couple of times.
I've laughed harder with that guy.
We did an episode of CSI together and we
just had the most off color fund in the
world,
but it was also,
you also got to understand the mentality
of the New York comedian were newer
comics are always trying to over
insult you to the point of being.
He just completely outrageous.
Like Jim Norton told a really funny
story on Opie and Anthony About Louis C K
and him hanging out and the in the village
and Lucy Kay just walks up to him and
slaps his pizza onto the ground and says,
your mother's a cunt like out of nowhere.
And Andy and Jim Norton is laughing.
While he's telling us and he's just like,
I was it juicy slice of pizza too.
I was so bad.
But it's like I read you the
text that will us and to me,
cause we have a relationship
like that where he just,
we tried to reach southeast
trash and making salt each other.
They'll worst we can.
He started calling me a mule and just,
and he sends me the most outrageous texts.
I can't even describe those relationships
with friends like that are fun.
Like people don't understand.
You try to get like Eddie Bravo and I
do that shit to each other all the time.
Go ahead and get [inaudible]. But anyway,
Gilbert Gottfried is in, you know,
he's a comic and when you're a comic,
you mean sometimes you're right shit and
you're writing shit really for people
like you and for fucking Gilbert,
if he was at home and he was
reading someone's Twitter
and he started saying all
this shit about Japan,
he would be laughing his fucking ass off.
It doesn't mean that
he's not a sensitive guy.
It doesn't mean that he doesn't feel
bad for all these people. It's just,
it's also funny. Well, I called
them one time I was doing,
but have you ever seen a little
Asian girl cry? It's so adorable.
And now times that by millions and it'll
Gilbert Godfrey, he's going over there.
No, listen man, I actually think
it's right to say those things,
but I think it's funny to
Gilbert. It's funny stuff. I mean,
it's funny to me to look, I feel
terrible about what happened in Japan,
but those were still good
jokes and you know, he's,
he's, yeah, they're good jokes,
but not good judge. Maybe depending your
Twitter. No, listen, I wouldn't say them.
I wouldn't say him for a
bunch of reason that says,
I wouldn't want to say anything that
would hurt anybody's feelings like that.
Especially someone who
just randomly got go.
I don't care how funny the joke is
to make, I don't think, but that's,
I don't think Gilbert is a Kinda guy.
Whoever,
he's not gonna no sacred cows
to him. He's one, he's gonna,
he's gonna say the joke and he's
a good guy. He's not a bad guy.
It's just that he's looking for the laugh.
There's a laugh there and he sees it
and as a comic you just goes for it and
then you know,
people freak out and get upset about it.
I'm sure he probably never expected, he's
from the age of no Internet, you know,
he's from the age where you
could say anything you wanted.
So you know those guys
they developed that way.
You forget how many people are not
into what you're talking about. Right.
You know, and that's what it
becomes. Yeah, it's, it's okay.
The only problem was that he's
a commercial artist as well.
He does commercials and
that that's what fucked him.
They pulled him off of a
campaign because you know, look,
obviously this is a terrible
tragedy, you know, and no one's,
no one's trying to make light of that,
but can't you can't you both mourn
for the people and laugh too.
Is that possible? And I was going to
say this is what I was going to say is,
is that, you know, for the
most part, I think in tragedy,
that's exactly what you need it.
The last thing,
somebody who's going through a tragedy
needs is a bunch of other people acting
really somber around that suppressing
happiness and laughter. And it's not,
I'm not saying that, you know, you
should be happy that that happened.
Of course not, but shouldn't, you know,
shouldn't we try to be the happiest we can
at all times? Always. Absolutely. And I,
and I think there's
always room for humor and,
and it does take some of the sting
out of it if I that's it's very soon.
But it rethink about how a lot of
times you do deal with, with things,
you start marking when you're
actually over something by how,
how easily you can make fun of it
and how easily you can take those.
So sometimes you're pushing
that too quickly obviously.
And I think there is a time to reflect
and be [inaudible] I think. But I agree.
But there's something to people about
making a joke about a situation as to not
being able to feel for the people
that, that, that are in that situation.
And it's not, it's just that
it got, it's so far removed,
it's way over there that he doesn't even
think about it. He just says the joke.
Right. I mean, I would never do it
and I know you would never do it,
but he's just a comic man. That's
what they do. And a good one.
And he's a comic that's like known for
saying like the most offensive one time I
was doing, I do every year I
do the uh, Doris Roberts, uh,
children with AIDS benefit. So we do
stand up. Kevin James does it sometimes.
It's a good time. Sarah Silverman and we
got up, we do, you know, 20 minutes in,
in this big thing. And I called
Gilbert to see if you wanted to do it.
And Gilbert Gilbert's a great, you
know, and I know him and he's, and he,
but he just kept going, fuck that
children and I go, no, but I said,
it's a benefit for it go
that Chels ran and ran.
I think he wouldn't stop saying that
until I finally had to hey, I was like,
oh fuck.
So He seems like when he's on Howard
stern that he very rarely has a real
conversation. Right. What
if this has to be funny?
What did the same shit happened in
California though? You're right,
and then he did a joke about how much
money we lost half of your friends.
You're right. You're right. You're in a
totally different with no, no, no. Right.
You're right.
There are guys in Japan and England.
Everyone else that wouldn't be saying,
I mean I agree with
you that it would hurt,
but I don't agree with you that he
shouldn't be able to say it. No,
you should say it,
but you see,
you put it on your Twitter and
openly almost brag like, look,
I'm being fucking edgy. I think he may
know you're pushing it in your face.
Like almost like being,
I think Gilbert told me
I had miscalculated and
made an error in judgment.
That's what twice he did
it twice or three times.
He did three different tweets. He
did a bunch of them. Yeah. All right.
He took them down. Unfortunately, I
don't think it's the mother on TMZ.
If anyone's looking for them,
they're on TMZ is website.
I think the second or third
page, I mean, you know,
I like Gilbert and I don't think he means
what he says and I think he was just
paying a comic. Yeah, and probably
just push the envelope a little. Oh,
we're apologists. So let me read it.
He's really good on Jay. Like here's,
here's what will Sasso wrote to
me. This is literally like, I just,
I'm just doing minding my own business
and I get this text from him and this is
our relationship and to speaking of kind
of being able to joke around, he goes,
you're a fucking meat pod. I go,
what? What's a meat? Patty goes,
AF, fucking anthropods made a
meat. You're a fucking hero.
You're a fucking all fours walking
meat. Puppet. Hey, meaty, meaty mule.
But it hang your slack face.
True.
Townline I can't even how you Mosey
around on all fours turned the Muli go
round. Hey Mule, get over here
and lick these. My town of my ass.
You guys sound like you're queer for
each other. Well, let me read this.
Jay Gilbert. Godfrey depend things. So
you're like a little child over there.
Here's one. Japan is really
advanced. They don't go to the beach.
The beach comes to them.
I just split up with my girlfriend.
But like the Japanese say there'll be
another one floating by any minute now.
Wow. That one's fucked up.
You know? But whatever, man,
if you're going to want these guys to
say fucked up shit about other things,
you're going to accept it
when it's something that you
know that either is close
to home or hurt your feelings
or, or you feel, I feel bad.
I absolutely feel bad
for the people that had,
if they had to hear those jokes and they
lost someone over there, absolutely.
It's terrible. But you
know, fuck. Is it worse?
The joke is the joke actually
make the idea of, I mean,
how could you hurt anybody
worse than losing a loved one?
There's nothing worse than a
joke is not gonna make it worse.
I was thinking about that just
to have your children, whatever.
It just washed away. Washed
dude. I watched some of those
videos. It's so terrible.
Some of those videos,
there's the initial video where it breaks
the wall and you see these boats come
over the top of this wall,
the seawall and start smashing through
houses and it's like, whoa man.
Like that is, it's unbelievable.
It's such heavy duty fury.
And then he realized how much fucking
water is there out there. It's an ocean,
dammit. Why would you live so
close to the ocean? You know,
like I was in Malibu this weekend.
We went to the,
there's a place called Malibu seafood
were nice place for, uh, you know,
like this is a good little fresh seafood
place in Malibu. And as we were driving,
I was looking at all these houses that
are like right on the beach and they're
ridiculously expensive. You know, for a
little tiny ass house it'd be like five,
6 million bucks, but they're really
expensive in Malibu and malleable.
And I'm like, wait a minute,
they're on the beach.
Like what kind of trust to you
fuckers have you got trusted?
That shit's going to stay there.
Like,
I remember the first
time I ever was in a car,
Hi Eddie Bravo was driving and we were
in Redondo beach and we were going over
this edge of this hill and I look off to
the left hand side and I see the ocean
and it was the first time it ever occurred
to me how much fucking water that is
just sitting right there. What we saw, the
Japan Japanese thing was just a little,
it was just like it moved
in and sleep like the ocean.
Just how amazing was this videos, by
the way, the houses just start just,
I mean incredible, right? It makes you
really realize what could happen if,
say there was a like a,
an asteroid impact or you know,
the Canary Islands that the east coast
has to worry about the Canary Islands
because apparently there's a volcanic
shelf that if it drops off and it will,
and it has in the past,
drops off into the ocean,
it will cause a fucking tidal
wave that will drown everyone.
A myelin on the east coast.
The whole northeast coast is just going
to get fucking slammed with this insane
amount of water. You know,
it's weird. Is that I, when,
when I watched that that wave come
through, I was, I thought, you know,
if the houses could withstand it sort of,
I mean they just go under locked,
you know what I know,
but instead it got all just up.
Even like telephone poles got up the
mass of that water is something I don't
exactly push. Yes. It's like a huge, like,
like the thing like the blob or whatever
that, right, right, right. Yeah.
Absorbs everything. Yeah. It's, it's, I
mean it's got fucking cars and ours. Yeah.
It's like a huge, like, um,
meet Masha stuffed and there's
so much energy behind it. I mean,
didn't they say that the tsunami wave
is traveling something like 500 miles an
hour?
I think when,
when once they get an earthquake on
the sh on the bottom of the ocean,
the ripple effect can be as fast
as six. They, I guess it's, yeah,
as long as I can start
underwater that, that fast. Like,
fuck, man, it's just energy.
I guess they said it created a,
a breach that was,
or I don't know what the
word they use to describe it,
but 50 miles wide and 270 miles long.
That's how,
how much moved on the bottom
of the earth's surface.
That's like those rogue waves when
you're on a cruise, the Horse,
he knows sometimes pluck a cruise
ship. Dude, fuck that fuck that.
I hated when I was on a creation
that scares the shit out like that.
Here's what I think about on cruises.
What a perfect way for a
maniac to randomly kill
Peter's throwing people off the
boat.
Do you think,
I've been on cruises at 12 at night noise
on that deck and at least on the boat
they don't have movies.
What's that shit called?
Where they say that people on boats
sometimes like gaze out into the ocean and
just jump off for some reason. Like
there's like a term for retard. No,
it they call it like oceans a
dream or something like that.
Like they get trapped by all
night. Yeah. And it's probably,
I always thought like it's
probably doesn't exist.
That condition is just people
getting murdered in another ocean.
The Odyssey though with the
Odyssey when at this year
hell is not to look at the sirens or
not to heat, listen to the sirens.
Because if you listen to them, you'll
jump in the water and try to, you'll,
you'll try to call them and then you,
you drown.
And a lot of the men didn't
cover up. Cover up their
ears. Yeah, it was the sirens.
And isn't there a Celtic myth
about something like that as well?
What was the o brother where art thou?
When the women in the water, they sirens.
What does that what they
were, no, they were like,
they were like temptresses I
love me. Those are great. Stop.
The Coen brothers are the best.
Right?
I forgive them even for movies that end
with no ending because I loved when they
just do weird shit. They just
take chances. Barton Fink. Yeah.
Great movie with John.
John Goodman and John Turturro to Fargo.
Man still holds up. Go back
and watch this. Oh yeah.
What the fuck bro? Alphas
good. I was that last night.
That doesn't have anything to do
with what we're talking about.
I've never seen alpha. I
can't, I can't comment on it.
I haven't told Pharos hilarious.
You know what I did see I went to see
red riding hood because of a fucking
completely fixated on where it with a,
I'm friends with the director of
Red Riding Hood. Really? Really?
Your friends with the chick who directed
twilight, you wearing a tampon and play.
Now I don't know where their
husband or their boyfriend. Jamie.
Could you guys talk twilight and did we,
did you ask her a series questions and
retained you enjoyed the movie. Okay. Now,
um,
do you think that they really love
each other or for me like I felt that,
but I just, he's a fan. Tell me,
please tell me that you got an insincere
conversation with the woman who was the
director of twilight about
how great the movie was. No,
we actually ended up playing running
charades. Please tell me. I wish I had,
she's cool man.
She's really,
I actually watched the first toilet
and I didn't have a problem with it.
I was like, well, it's not a bad movie,
but there's been way worse movies.
It's not for me. It's not my generation.
It's for children. The second one,
the book's amazing,
Kendall,
try to lift the boat. I got to the, I
think it was the second one. I was like,
all right, this is getting
fucking dumb. Yeah. This, they
dropped off substantially.
Second first one was pretty decent and
good job capturing that teenage anx,
that Achy love.
Yeah.
It's like an Achy love sorta horror
movie was kind of like Achy love,
but more exciting than the usual
whiny bullshit. Kristen Stewart.
I don't know what it is about her,
but I just wanted to, you know,
she's my friend John's daughter. Really?
Yeah. Jon Stewart was, uh, the, uh, the,
I guess, I don't know his actual
position. Assistant Director,
I guess on a fear factor. He was the
guy who organized everything on a sat.
He said, great, super pro. He's
one of these guys, talks like this.
We got you over there, buddy. Have a seat.
We'll be get shade and five get to you in
five just always on the ball, you know,
juggles the whole shit
like a fucking champion.
Like we had a bunch of people that did
that job and they will all stumbled and
fucked up and people, it's just too much
work. But this guy is like an old pro.
He's been around forever.
And he was telling me about his daughter
doing some movie with Jodie foster.
I'm like, Yo, why are you linking your
daughter act? I know. What's that about?
And then meanwhile listen to me,
I mean his daughters now is like one of
the most famous actresses in the fucking
world and you know,
she's probably made enough money to
retire for the rest of our lives making a
lot of money. She's so
pretty. Something about her.
I just find so like she doesn't try,
she's just,
she doesn't really even wear makeup. She
just, she just is. So just so you know,
there's so much to be said for people
who can just be present and not,
not try to do anything and
not try to be [inaudible].
Before we start any
conversation about a girl,
I have to tell you that you know that
you are always attracted to girls that
look like then me cry.
You're the guy who comes over and the
girl is standing out in the rain and you
and she looks like she's going
to cry and you're like, hey,
look what I found [inaudible] you let me
get on my horse and ride over there and
saving the Damsel. Loved
that. That's the best.
That's the funniest and best
way to describe, uh, Giovanni,
you and I have talked about this many
times, but you'd never said I've had to,
I had to rescue you a few times.
I had to
actively ignored you a couple times,
which almost cost me my house.
There was one time where I ran into Brian
and Brian and I were in Hollywood and
he said,
Oh,
I'm going to bring this girl bothered
them date and I would love to see it.
And she goes, hi, nice to meet you. And
I shake her hand, look at him. I go,
come here for a second. And
I go, well, let's take them
outside. I go, listen to me.
I go, she's crossing crazy. I
have like the most ridiculous,
crazy radar. And when, when someone's,
when there's something really wrong with
someone, my body goes on red alert. What?
She was on Meth when she met
you? Yeah. Meanwhile I know,
I didn't know what the hell, I just
thought she had an energy squirly as fuck.
As soon as she came over,
dude,
she was so off the charts bizarre
and shaky and weird and she just,
she's just saying hello to me. I pull
him aside. All she said is, hello,
nice to meet you. And then I go,
Whoa, come here for a second.
And I take him outside and I go,
she's fucking critical.
We let's get Outta here right now. Let's
get out of here right fucking now just,
you don't have to say goodbye to her.
Just call her Toni.
You're never going to hang
out with her again. Anyway,
belonging and the story is chaos.
All sorts of things happen.
He breaks up with her and then many,
many years later,
how many years later was it that you
saw her walking? Uh, tell the store,
walking down the street, right about a
year. Tell the story. Keep it Kinda, okay.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. That's, we're on the DL
when not name any names. Yeah, I know. No,
it's just the date of a hundred methods.
That's true.
I could have been any one
of them. My thing, uh,
nothing really good comes out of
that whole, that whole drug man.
It's nobody ever said, hey, I did
math and, and everything worked out.
I just know the method advocates province
and I did some math and everything.
Just I got a new house and my
body looks great. You know,
it looks kept tricky though.
What's tricky is that Adderall stuff,
which is kind of like a speed,
right? I mean, isn't that
a form of speeds, cocaine,
cocaine? I said that's where the kid
is probably, that's what it felt.
It feels like to me when I, when I did
it, it just felt like I was on cocaine.
Well that's probably because most of the
cocaine you got was cut with an Arrow
with speed. Speed. Oh yeah. Yeah. So
I think it's like a speed speeding.
Yeah.
Because I'm the late great
Robert Schimmel. God bless him,
rest his soul and all that good
stuff. Great Guy. He, he told me once,
I ran into him just randomly and he told
me about accidentally taking someone's
Adderall.
He thought it was something else.
He thought it was like his blood pills,
you know,
he had a heart attack and he thought
it was a, and he had cancer. You know,
he's had a lot of fucking
serious health problems mixing,
maybe didn't have a heart attack,
maybe just a cancer. Anyway,
he had some serious health
problems and he, um, he, uh,
took this Adderall by mistake and he
called his doctor. He's like, Holy Shit,
I think I took Adderall by mistake. What
do I do? He said, he can't do anything.
Just kick back and enjoy the ride because
it's going to be with you for the next
12 hours, but you're going to
be fine. He goes for 12 hours.
I just organize all my notes. He
goes, I just started writing. He goes,
I got so much shit done. Let you take
it for it to be more clear. Yeah.
Some people take it and it like
add people usually take it. Yeah.
Buddy minds on it. He's on it all
day. He's, you know, him to it.
We'll talk about it off the air, but he's
on it all day. He's, he takes it all day,
every day. He's prescribed by a
doctor. Really? Yeah. I, I dunno,
you know what specifically they
said he needed it for it, but man,
he's so fucking workaholic now,
but it's like that fucking movie that's
coming out with Bradley Cooper, you know,
limitless where you take a pill and all
of a sudden this pill makes you like
super focused and that I'm sure they're
going to come up with. That's Adderall,
Bro. I mean, there's a lot of fucking
people on Adderall. I didn't even,
I found out about Adderall when I was
on fear factor because there was a pas,
you know, production assistants and the
production assistants. Um, we're all, uh,
like college kids, you know, they were all
like doing it. Like a lot of them were,
you know, they're doing
it for a, you know,
just getting out of school first
Gig and they're doing it, you know,
as a part of the classes. Um, and uh,
they would start talking about how they
would take Adderall and while they're in
school. So I was like, you know, kids are
taking Andrew like, what are you doing?
And they're like, oh my God, I can't
even go to school without Adderall.
I was like, what? Like
what are you talking about?
It's what I thought was interesting about
that. You see that documentary bigger,
faster, stronger. Yes. And
you know, people say, well,
you're taking steroids and then ended up
be gene doping and all kinds of things
and pretty soon I have nano technology
that kind of oxygenates your blood. But,
but, but, but they said, you
know, steroids or illegal,
but yet performance can take
Beta blockers for example,
that actually keep them from getting
nervous where the debate really,
and they really, they're allowed, that's
legal. I mean, you know, if apparently,
I mean an orchestra,
one of the guys was an orchestra violinist
and he takes Beta blockers because it
helps him. He otherwise he doesn't get
nervous. He's much better at playing.
The issue is that is a performance
enhancing drug. You could,
you could make the argument and,
right,
but that's like the difference
between violins and steroids.
It's a pretty big into
question but, but, but the,
the debate's still is they're both
performance enhancing drugs. One,
make sure muscular cause that's what was
required in your particular endeavor.
Right? Whereas the other one, make
sure your fingers are more relaxed,
whatever it might be. It's just an
interesting debate. You kind of go,
where do you draw the line? I say personal
freedom is where you draw the line.
I think you should be able to
do whatever you want to do.
If you want to take Adderall and
write books all day, good for you.
Why would I get into the choice?
It's
like,
it's like when Bloomberg in New York,
Mayor Bloomberg made restaurants
where we're not allowed to, um,
uh, provide foods that had trans fats. I
believe. I don't know if that law went to,
but that was the, that was
the exactly. Our Trans fats.
I think trans fatty acids with
penises. No, I think twins.
Brian just knocked it out of the park.
There it is. That's why he's here folks.
I think it's like,
I think I'm partially,
I think I partially hydrogenated oils,
whatever it is,
it's not good but delicious.
Right. You know what I mean?
I don't want to be able to eat. Not
good but delicious. Sometimes you fuck,
you're going to make a trans
fats illegal. Let's go. Let's,
let's make up two things.
Let's take white flour and sugar.
We charge a real fucking cigarettes man.
Before they even touch you.
Draw the line. White flour and
sugar. Make some delicious donuts.
That's where you draw the line. Eat
too many of them. You'll get diabetes,
so give me a break. You're
going to make it. You can't.
You got to figure out where to draw the
line and you start with water. Yeah.
People should be able to make their own
choices based on the information that
they can.
And nowadays everybody can get information
and I'm always amazed as somebody,
people don't spend more time taking a
look at what they put in their bodies.
But some people worry about what access
to children. This is like the big word.
Yeah, yeah, I hear that about
adults. But what about my kids?
I don't want my kids who worry.
It's never been,
it's never not been a worry that the
answer to that is not to take away adult's
ability to choose things for themselves.
It doesn't make the world a safer place.
You want to try and make the world
a safer place. You let's, let's,
let's take one example.
Lower the speed limit is 36 miles an hour.
It'll save lives. I can measure
that for you. Mathematically.
You want to lower the speed
limit? No. B We're going to,
we're going to have it at 55
65 because that's the way life.
That's the s the pace life moves at.
And by the way,
people die at that pace but
nobody's going to slow down.
Cause the slow down is ready,
not worth it.
So you're putting a price on human life,
which we do every single day
as a society and we have to,
that's an interesting way to put it.
You could spend more money on airlines.
You could spend actually
more money to really,
really triple safe guard planes.
You could actually do,
it wouldn't be worth it because price for
everybody would go up and you wouldn't
able to fly that way.
It's it's we do.
We make these decisions subconsciously
and consciously every single day.
My friend Johnny used to said,
why don't they put a big
parachute at the top of the plane?
It's like such a smart thing that great.
I thought about that.
I'm like God dammit.
That's like some gene shit,
don't they let even talks about it.
I like when they find that when they,
when they find that black box as like why
don't they just make the whole plane I
made out of the same shit. Those
hack in 87 it sure was. Well,
what are they at least give
you parachutes her, you know,
like underneath your seat just
in case if you fucking way, Bro,
500 miles an hour, you're fucked.
Fall out of the sky. We usually,
most plane crash has happened on
takeoff and landing, so that's,
that's so they're, your peer at
parachutes can not going to do shit.
It's not like you're in the
air and the light you need
is some sort of a adamant Tanium to shit
that wolverines bones is made out of
like a shield that you put around
you on impact because impact they,
the percussion. Your brain would
be you, maybe you or just the,
my brain would be fine, bro.
Or just a huge shot of heroin
with bubbles and stuff.
I got padding. Maybe you brought
her, Joe's getting competitive. You,
he's going to competitively.
Oh, can take more impact.
This is a stupid conversation.
I hate this podcast.
What?
Last night when I was a showrooming and
went outside and looking at the stars
when you're showrooming is the most
fucking amazing thing in the whole entire
world.
They were just pulsating.
You're riding a dolphin right now to put
according blowing him talking pin over
right now, writing and Unicorns
licking his ass. He's got,
hey around his asshole on the
Unicorn slick here as I frolic.
I want to share him every day. Don't
think that's good for you, for him.
I think that's what happened to
the Mayans. That's my latest.
I have this bit about the
Mayans, about the mines. Uh,
you know the reason why they came
up with this end of the world, shit,
there were fucking doing mushrooms
and like staring at space all day.
Like there's a certain amount of mushrooms
you should stop at and whatever the
fuck the Mayans did cause they
disappeared. You know, the people,
the Mayan people are still there.
That's what's weird.
When I went to cheat you an Eatsa,
I went and uh,
one of them went on the tour of
the ruins and everything like that.
There's people there that look
like those Mayan sculptures.
There's like pick people there that have
those Mayan features and they're really
tiny people. It's really bizarre. So the
Mayans, it's not like they all died off,
but whatever.
The fuck they were doing was so crazy
that it got to a point with human
sacrifices just fell apart
doing human sacrifice.
I call that pretty crazy and raiding
other villages in a might've been a lot of
it might've been that they
were just getting fucked up
on mushrooms all the time
and just go to war on mushrooms and we
knew the Vikings went to Warren Mushrooms.
They will become very Scotts. The Scotts
they call them deserves. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know what mushroom they took.
I'm sure someone on Twitter will tell us,
but I think it was the Amanita Mascara,
which is the one that's linked to Siberia
and Santa Claus and cause they would
get naked rain, make it and they say
they'd cry a lot. Yeah. Well you know,
listen man, if you've fucking put
yourself on the right mixture,
you know and you've got to go to war,
you put yourself on some crazy
next dimension. Mixture. No,
you have to go to war. We think of
war. It's like something to be avoided.
But when you're in your living in
one a d it's, there's no avoiding it.
Is this dude's with swords and they're
coming on horses and we got to get a
spear. When the weird thing is, the
way they went, they would fight.
I always think about this,
the fine line.
Do you want me to charge into all of that?
That,
that all those blades to just fight
like that? It's high. I'd be waiting.
I want to be the sniper I want to be.
There was no avoiding that.
That shit happened. I've learned the bone
Arrow quick. Yeah, but even that man,
eventually someone's gonna run
up on you and hack your leg off.
It's a bad way to God, a crazy way to go
to all those fucking Braveheart movies.
Two armies, they meet across a field
and they just run at each other now,
but they really walk it like that.
At least they had the anesthesia
in antibiotics by the time. Right.
I didn't stop to bend over to tie
my shoe in my metal shoe laces.
Do you how sucky it was lived back then.
Oh, you died a things like tetanus,
diphtheria, whooping cough, small pop up,
starvation and animal attacks,
starvation animal attacks.
Other other like countries
coming in and going, hey,
we're going to kill you and enslave
your kids and rape you are wise.
No. What people have forgotten about
man wolves is all this talk level.
We're going to save the wolf. The wolf
are amazing. Majestic creatures. Yeah.
Wolf's used to eat fucking kids,
man.
There's a reason why all these little Red
Riding Hood with that movie that I saw,
all of these things would though the
three little pigs you use the reason why
there's wolves and all these children's
stories cause wolves would fucking eat
your kids there. They're out there man.
And they're getting stronger and bigger.
Do you hear about the wolf
pack in Siberia or in uh,
it was somewhere in the Soviet Union
but we're forming. So wherever Russia,
whatever it's called now
400 a found meet. Uh, they had
found bear DNA and they're at feces.
They were killing bears,
right?
Well no,
that's the one I'm talking about.
I'm talking about this a pack of Super
Wolves who was 400 wolves in this Russian
town and they were killing horses that
were ganged up cause it got so cold
apparently that all the
animals that they prey on died.
So they started breaking into places and
killing horses and there's 400 of them
acting as a superpac first of all,
living in Siberia in the wintertime.
And they, and they're like, hmm.
Well I'm not sure if
it's Iberia at somewhere.
Obviously incredibly cold in
Alaska because everything died.
Everything froze to death. Now isn't
that a lot of freezing to death lately,
man in Japan or in Vietnam?
7,000 fucking uh,
I think it was oxen, oxen or what
are some wild cow or something?
Whatever the fuck it was, but 7,000 large
animals died. Wow. You know, I mean with,
while these, these massive die offs, you
know, that that's happening this year.
I mean all of them together. I don't
remember. I don't remember any die offs.
Just a few employees happen, I think. And
I think in nature you always have dives.
And by the way, you also always have
viruses that come in and wipe out,
for example, wild dog of Africa and
that that dog, you know a lot of,
from what I've read and seen,
I believe they get,
one of them gets this temper and
then the whole pack dies. You know,
they just spread it back and forth.
I have a dog that had to stamp her.
It was scary as fuck.
It's scary.
A rescue dog.
He was a doberman and he was real sweet
and then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
man, he just started snapping at me and
growled at me and I was a little kid.
I was like 11
one of the great things we've done as
human beings and the 20th century is
really checked. Most pathogens,
most diseases like that we have,
we have come up with a bill,
an ability to really make them slim to
vanishing in our everyday lives. Who,
when was the last time you knew
anybody who died of a disease?
And if you read any kind of literature,
any literature, pick up any book from,
from even 1948,
even though even if you place there,
there was always, everybody had
dealt with different kinds of play,
whether it was influenza in this,
in the worldwide influenza that
hit this country in a very,
very hard in the 20s or, um, or polio,
which put the countless
children, thousands of
children in, in on iron lungs.
They died. And then they lost their,
their ability to walk. And the,
our own president,
I mean,
our own president of the United States
got polio and was in a wheelchair.
Now think about that. You know, um,
when he was governor of New York, uh,
Theodore Roosevelt, I'm
sorry, it was, um, uh,
Franklin Roosevelt was, uh, was, you know,
uh, I think he was coming to
New York. Yeah, it was, and,
but he was basically walking and standing
and then he got polio when he was at
the height of his power and yeah,
at the height of his powers when
he caught it. Yeah, yeah. Written.
Then he became president.
I said,
there's no doubt that it's
the safest time to live ever.
There's never been a time like this, you
know, with all the violence that we have,
think of the population,
the population has dramatically increased.
When people say, well, things aren't
like they were in the Sevis motherfucker.
Do you know how many more people there
are than the were in the 70s in the 70s
there was probably only 3 billion
people in the world or something.
The other thing is amazing is we've
figured out ways to harness food like you
know, India wide swaths of India and
Southeast Asia and especially in China,
went through terrible famines and never
had enough to eat and a lot of that,
a lot of that stuff is a memory.
Thank it seems to me though that these
things are happening much more frequently.
I would like to think that it's just
because of our access to information that
we have with the Internet and
Twitter and all these things.
So what we find out about
disasters, whether it's in
Chile, whether it's in China,
whether it's a New Zealand, find about
him, find out about them in real time.
But I don't buy that. And Man, I
feel like there's more. I mean,
I guess someone should do the research
or maybe somebody already has and I just
need to find the site.
But there's,
I think more things are happening
now than I can ever. I think.
I think I'm trying to be objective,
but I think we all have a tendency as
human beings also number one to first of
all,
I don't think there's ever been a time
in history when people weren't predicting
the end of our race shore. And now,
and I'm talking about first century,
the first centuries, pharisees, I mean,
you know, are the scenes. I mean that the,
in the Bible, that's what they talk about.
They were apocryphal, you know, and, and,
uh, that is, that is so much
a part of our nature, I think,
not only to always imagine
disaster and prepare for disaster,
but to predict disaster.
And, and I think that, um,
the one thing that's for sure is
that you will always deal with these,
what they call black swans,
these sorts of aberrations that come
out of nowhere and take the whole chess
board and throw it in the air.
And that is as much about the
human experience as anything else.
And I think that if you always keep in
mind that all this can be taken away from
you or can change you or can
throw your what, what your,
your whole contract that you came to
this table with in the rip it to shreds.
Is that a problem?
No one's that contract.
This is the real problem
with human beings.
We all just exist and we don't really
think about what the fuck is truly going
on until something nutty happens.
That's right. And by the way,
remember a lot of psychiatrists
to tell you that all,
all of us come to the table with
a contract. Like we, we, we,
we all make deals with ourselves.
We say, if I work really hard,
I'm going to get this job. If I work
really hard, I'm going to get famous.
If I remember the how to get,
I'll,
I'll make a lot of money and a lot of
times life doesn't work that way for a
whole myriad of reasons. A
lot of times, by the way,
it's because people aren't honest with
themselves and don't realize what they're
actually good at versus what
they want to be good at.
We see that a lot with
acting and all these things,
but I think you see it everywhere and but,
but at the end of the day, most of us,
it's really interesting the social
scientist because they'll say,
well a lot of times we have a
contract come to the table and we say,
this is what happens. We get
older, it doesn't happen.
But human beings are also really,
really good at creating what they call
synthetic happiness. They can, they can,
they can assess what they got now versus
what they did want and they realized it
didn't work out and then they'll just
start to really love what they like.
There's social sciences did a really
interesting study between people who won
the lottery and then people who became um,
uh,
paraplegics and he and he measured their
sort of happiness on a broad sort of
scale,
uh,
a year later and found that there were
both in the same place because the people
in a wheelchair, I had done such a good
job of embracing their new reality.
And that just means a lottery winners
or retards. That's all I'm saying.
It's crazy. But he was, you got
know if you won the lottery, dude,
you'd be way happier than you'd
be if you were in a wheelchair,
unless you're an idiot. Well, but I'm
just saying it's human beings human.
It's more a comment on the people in the
wheelchair who are able to kind of what
I was saying,
man,
when I was saying that the people
aren't exactly aware of what's going on.
Here's the deal.
We live in a society that was collected
over the course of hundreds of years of
innovation.
It's created all of the work of millions
of people that you've never met, right.
And all of their combined efforts and
discoveries have allowed you to live this
really simple and easy life and that's
what we're all doing and we are all
raising children with the same ignorance
that we have about what this is all
about in this country, in this
country, in all countries.
No one knows what the next stage of
this existence. I think for example,
if you look at India and then you
look at China and especially India,
India is becoming a real hot bed
of innovation and those kids work.
They, I mean there's a their
slaves. No, they weren't.
I call them when my Dell
computer doesn't work,
but they're smart and a lot of that
innovation is coming out of India.
I'm sure there is man and what all
I'm sure it is what I'm saying.
What I'm getting at is no one has
earned this life that we live right now.
No one that's alive has, it's a
collective effort, but as individuals,
very few of us are even putting into
perspective normal things like our own
mortality, the mortality of a
very climate, the mortality of,
of the structure and the shape of the
continents. I think because it a lot of,
and a lot of ways we're more comfortable
today than we ever have been.
Plenty to eat. You can go away biology,
you don't worry about these disease.
Do you even really have to worry
about war? For the most part,
that's new in our country.
Remember in 2011 if you take even 1985
half the world was under communist
dictatorships who were,
who had their missiles pointed
directly at our major cities.
That doesn't exist anymore. There
really is for all intensive purposes.
One superpower,
one military superpower in the world
and Russia is no longer a threat.
Think about that.
We now have NATO.
Most of the eastern European countries
that were our enemies are actually part
of NATO. Now, who do you talk
about? North Korea and Iran?
Maybe significant to an extent,
but certainly nothing like the
threat that the Soviet Union was.
So I think people,
you're right.
I think people for the most part
are a lot more relaxed and, and,
and feeling a lot more secure. Anything
is better now. People are smarter now.
People are nicer now.
People are more aware and informed.
Now they're more aware of their own
mental and psychological problems.
We're fatter now. Bigger asses. Now
the question becomes
what's the balance like?
How much discomfort do you have to
experience, to beat, to be great?
Because I think greatness does
come out for it to a large extent.
Out of doesn't come out of comfort
and luxury. I think it does,
but sometimes it can just come out of
discipline. Well, they're struggling.
That discipline. If you can be the
type of person that really, you know,
you don't have to be living a terrible
life. That's right. You're right.
Good stuff.
You know,
you can be living a great life as long
as you're disciplined and you really tune
yourself into it as you're right.
Yeah. You know, but you were talking,
I thought I had a thought. You
were talking about how, you know,
genetic suck and pretty soon,
you know,
we're going to be able to kind of choose
our genetics. But the question becomes,
you know, I think of myself well, but
the problem with that is that so much.
I'm worried that we'd lose our color
cause so much of what I do and what drives
me worried really is the white color
white people. No, no, no color.
Like color flavor, flavor.
Oh, nice. Recovery.
Not Color. I mean like our flavor
hour, hour. Because, because,
because so much of what we do,
so much of what I do,
what drives me is that I'm compensating
for my inadequacies or my perceived
inadequacies that that's why I worked out.
That's why I did martial arts.
That's why I wrestled.
I felt like I was sort of,
but it's always from the childhood, the
place that a performer comes from. Yeah.
And me too. And everyone, we
know, everyone we know that's
a comic. There's always,
but what I'm saying is in some ways, God
bless a dysfunctional childhood. Yeah.
And no, because you're one of a
hundred that didn't, you know,
there's a hundred like you that smashed
on the rocks and the way up to the top
of the cliff.
You managed to bite through vines with
your teeth and get to the top and you
took a deep breath and now you're okay.
But you didn't have to be okay.
I needed to die.
Anyone with a fucked up childhood,
like the idea of encouraging a fucked up
childhood to create an innocent child.
What did you really mean?
That's really what you're saying,
but the trick of light truly isn't.
The trick of life isn't the trick of life
to turn to turn that which is bad into
something good. Yes, it is the trick,
but some people fail at that trip and
then we have criminals wandering through
the streets that are dangerous
and emotionally get matched.
It's very easy to destroy the human being.
It's not hard at all.
And they'll just raise him terrible.
Yup. You know what I mean? When you,
it's always like some feral child and
Russia. You hear about raised by dogs,
you know like, oh wait, fuck
right. You just stop and
think about it. Like with the,
for the kid's been eating
dead birds and shit for dogs,
dogs but like poodles
or something like that.
Like what's so weird about
contemplating like disaster,
like the one in Japan, any disaster or
any, anything has a ripple effect. And,
and the crazy thing is that that
sometimes to one person's loss is another
person's opportunity.
It's just that dance that constantly
goes back and forth and there's one side,
something terrible happens and it opens
up a whole new world and opportunity for
a whole nother group of people. You
know, whether it's up, somebody opens a,
I dunno,
a company that provides quick relief
and now he's employed 60 people who can
feed their kids, whatever the case.
It's just this constant dance man.
And whenever you try to pinpoint or
treat life like it's a noun, you're,
you're in trouble. And by the way,
your relationships are a verb.
Everything is a verb. Everything is
always moving. Everything is in flux.
You are too. Absolutely. That's the
whole thing is there's nothing static,
but that's what everybody looks at is
the problem with the contract with coming
to the table with the contractors.
They look for that moment where
they can stop now, man. I think,
I think if you keep growing
and you keep yourself,
you keep surprising and shocking
yourself and maybe even scaring yourself,
which is hard to do. But if you
sound like an actress right now,
have to sing a song, dude,
got away on my song, you know,
selling some new chick the
next blockbuster terracing
about why the fuck I am
beautiful. The worst earthquake, you know,
everyone's talking about what
Gilbert Gottfried said. No one is,
no one said dumber shit than
what's Sharon Stone said? Well,
half the Chinese earthquake, or do you
remember that? She said, maybe you know,
I'm friends with the Dalai Lama.
You know,
maybe this earthquake in China is Karma
because they're of the terrible things
they've done for Tibet.
Wow. I remember that.
You think innocent people thought
squashed by rocks,
all that you know,
and she's a name drop and little Twat.
I'm fencing Itali Lama sure asked you
a hooker thinks about you all the time.
Concert when he's doing his mantra. He
was like, Sharon Stone, Sharon Stone,
you know Sharon, you know the girl
basic instinct actresses? No, excuse me.
You mean the girl from above the law,
the Steven Seagal debut
movie actors including me.
Look at the fact that we worship actors.
The funniest thing in the way,
if an alien came down, they'd
be like, wait a minute.
You're worshiping these people who are
basically good at being emotionally
available and pretending is, is that
really something that I, it's a skill.
It tells a good story there. Part
more impressive that. Or Golf. Golf.
Golf takes unlikely though.
But I like movies and Tiger Woods
probably can't act fuck golf. I love,
I don't know man.
I think both are equally ridiculous and
I've always said that it's one of the
funniest things in the world that people
think that's a guy's a hero because he
hits a ball into a hole in the ground.
But you know what I mean? So silly.
We don't really like about any comp comp,
competition,
golf or any game is that it requires
when you want to win at that game,
it requires you to do basically
do all that self examination,
that a face up to all your your obstacles.
You got to deal with
your performance anxiety.
You know how it is to try to get better.
You see the signers to choke.
That's the point of competition.
I probably would love golf.
That's what I'm terrified
but I played pool.
That's the only ever don't ever pick
up a golf. Don't ever take Guilford.
Going to I know how to only
chess either for the same reps.
For those of you guys who don't,
who don't know this about Joe Rogan I,
well I always said most of the public
actually doesn't knows very little about
Joe. For example. He can,
he can draw really well.
He's at a notch below probe to
clarify. He is. He is. He but he's,
he knows more about pool and he's,
he's actually a really good draftsman.
You can draw like really,
really well.
I've been wanting to do when I was in high
school before I got into martial arts.
But I mean, but and so, so the comic book
on you're a great lunch, you're real,
you're a real martial artist. You'd
be a nightmare to fight you. You can,
you can draw a really well
and you, um, short, balding,
Short, balding donkey assholes. Never
as clean. Are you not wearing pants?
CELEXA layered underneath.
But wait, I was,
there was a point I was making and I'm
too high to remember it. Dammit. Um,
pool playing games.
But the problem is that you're so
intense that once you pick something up,
it's like that game quake when you played
for 15 passed out as you were leaving
your eye. He drags me to the store and
he's getting these handles and did,
he's like 30,
he's getting,
he's getting his handles and all these
like weird things. It's, and I was like,
what are you doing? What's
all these? What are these,
what are these grips and stuff?
He goes,
it's for quake a playing somebody
in Sweden tomorrow I will crush him.
And I was like, whatever. What
the thousand yard stare, dude,
that'd be play connect to you.
You have no idea how we've talked about
this in the podcast way too many times,
but a quick is too fun.
Quake is even more involving than pool.
I won't allow my son's to those
games because they're too good. Now,
like gears of war, like we cliffy be
put up an epic games put up the, uh,
unreal three engine, the new
engine, they put up a demo.
Fucking hey man, it just doesn't, it
looks real. It looks like a fucking movie,
man. It's so, I do this
joke now about, about, um,
how we're fighting wars now like that,
you know, like with songs and stuff,
the guys in Nevada and Florida,
think about that.
You're killing somebody 5,000 miles away,
but it's a video game and
you're actually taking life.
You wonder what that does
to you psychologically when
you come home and you're
eating dinner. But, but I was at,
my joke was like, in 20 years,
the word hero is not going to be the
grizzled guy with the shaved head and the
scars. Can it be the Chubby dude with huge
thumb muscles who smells like Doritos.
We'd,
well that's true.
You Starfighter remember the movie where
the kid had to get really good at a
video game and when he got good at it,
they came down and took him to fight
in the galaxy. It's going to be,
well these Pakistan drone things are
fucking frightening because it's such a
gray area too.
It's like we're not really in Pakistan,
but we are in the sky above pag and,
but there's no one in the plane and,
and you hear it. This,
when I was in Afghanistan,
I wash those things taken
off all the time. I was like,
look at that thing. It's,
it's not even, it's not even manned. It
just takes off dude. Hell fire missiles.
That's all you need to know. What are you
doing buddy? This cliff VBS, epic games,
Infinity Blade video game.
They go through,
they go through like that
Hellfire missile, I think.
I believe somebody told me you can go
like a foot of steel or something like off
of steal.
The idea behind it is so crazy that you
can just pilot something from halfway
across the world in real time and
trust it to just eat your pro.
You pull the trigger and only the
beginning. How much of a delay is the lag?
There has to be some lag.
Well I don't know.
You can actually watch it on
the interview cause that was a,
that's a big thing about playing online.
When you play on line it's all about your
pain and if you have like one ping or
two paying,
like you're in the server,
you're local to the matter
anymore though so fast.
That doesn't mean what you need makes
a big difference would ping is in
milliseconds.
It absolutely matters.
It's the guy with a higher paying
than you can still beat you.
But you definitely have an
advantage when you're local.
Like say if this is like say if
we set up a server in my house,
right and I set up a server and
I'm here connected to the machine,
but other people have to connect and get
the information through the Internet.
So they're paying,
say if they're down the block at the
lowest they're going to get is maybe a 10
this is back in the day. I don't know
if it's changed, but yeah, 10 pin.
If you're lucky,
but that's cause you're here,
but if you're in Sweden or somewhere
like that, no doubt about it,
you're going to have a slight delay.
It might be 150 milliseconds.
It might be 200 milliseconds. It won't
be a full second. That's unbearable.
You can't do that. 250 milliseconds
is where it gets squirrely.
Like you can't really weird that does
the human human reaction can get to the
point where you can't make
like you can barely measure it.
Like when they do sprinting, you know, how
would the Olympics, you know when they,
you know why they shoot the gun? They
shoot a comment. That's for a sound.
That's for a fact. They
actually, if you're a,
if you're running a hundred like Usain
bolt and you're, you're in a rice, they,
they have that. They shoot
that sound off behind you. Why?
Because it's got to reach all the guys at
the same time. You shouldn't like this.
The guy at the end is the last to hear
about it and they're so fast off the
blocks that they, the other guy's
already already going to win the race.
You didn't hear it in
time. So they, they, they,
they found that when they shot back in
the day, they'd be shooting it here.
The guy closest to gun all would
always have this advantage. And so now,
and even when they, they send that
sound off now behind these guys,
the problem is the sound dissipates
to here. So it starts, you know,
you gotta have it, you gotta
have, it originates somewhere.
How do you get it to all of them at the
exact same second cause they're so fast
off the blocks,
you're actually giving the guy who hears
it first and advantage and they win.
It's like, it's like the guy
and check this out. You know,
the difference between fourth place and
first place in the downhill ski event
was in a, in a, you know, whatever it was.
It was two planks of an I can't
gain it says what? Ready Gold, gold,
gold, nothing. Gold. Nothing. Whoa.
Nothing. That's fucking not, that's
why swimmers trimmed their fingernails.
That's what he's and
he's don't don't trim.
They try to get their finger nails long.
Why?
To Act as like a little paddles notes so
that you can touch because it's you're
dealing with a hundredth of a second.
Watson can grow pimp nails. You tried it,
you tried it.
It's all computerized.
The minute you touch that and say if
you were touching like who some are Paul
horror as you'd be a terrible
swimmer because he wasn't real.
Have that big reach guys or albatrosses.
That's fucking fast.
That's how fast human being
how, okay. Let me ask you this.
How many of those guys
do you think are doping?
in Olympic competition?
I don't think it's possible to compete
in in a lot of Olympic sports without
doping and without doing drugs.
Yeah, like cycling. There's no way.
Why do you think all of them,
why do you think all of them get caught?
All of them. The biggest. It's the
biggest joke. I mean, you know, but, but,
but you're going after Lance Armstrong
Bro. I'm sure they're going after him.
This is, which is weird. It's
like they get them on lying,
which is a very strange thing.
It's like women,
if you're going to put
people in jail for lying,
how about most of the government?
You know, fuck can't in a lie.
Nobody ever got went to
jail for taking steroids.
But people who have gone to jail
for lying to the government about,
and if they take him his money away or if
they take, you know, say that you know,
you did some stuff that was
against the rules and you know,
you should be fine and we can
prove that that's one thing.
But they're going after
him to lock him up, man.
They're going after him till to set an
example and lock him up for something
that everyone's doing it. Everyone
is doing, especially in cycling,
I remember he wouldn't be
arrested for doing steroids.
They wouldn't lock them up for that.
They would lock him up for committing.
Perjury is a big diff weird, right?
That's how they got al Capone.
That's how they get
it, right? The word no,
the got him on tax evasion case against
Barry Bonds is that the case is you
perjured yourself on the stand,
right. Where does that like what?
You have to tell us the truth and if
you don't it's a crawl. You don't know.
You have to, you know you have
the right to take the fifth right.
But as you can say nothing, which is
what one of the great things about our,
you know our system,
you can actually not,
you can choose to not
incriminate yourself. I have,
I refused to speak cause I don't want
to incriminate myself and that's right,
but don't they lock people
up when they do that?
You can be locked up if you are given,
I believe now I'm not legal scholarship.
It's a scholarship that they're
doing that all the time.
I believe you can be locked up is if
you have evidence and the government
subpoenas that evidence and you
refuse to speak. If you say,
I'm not telling them my friend,
you can go to jail for that.
They can put you in jail for that.
And they have,
they put a journalist in jail because
she wouldn't divulge her sources.
And I believe that was in the Valerie
Plame case. That's creepy shit. She said,
I'm not going to divulge who told me
these con that this person was a CIA
operative or whatever and she went to
jail. And then scooter Libby, I, I'm,
I'm not sure if I'm getting all my facts
right, but scooter Libby, they'd find it.
Turns out was pardoned by the president
later on, but convicted of, um,
telling, uh, divulging a, an agent,
a u s agents identity to
a non authorized person,
uh,
which is a crime in this country.
It's so bizarre how many different people
we have all over the world that are in
military bases and you know,
that are, that are, uh,
government operatives
in the United States.
And we have them positioned all over the
world to kind of keep an eye on every,
always have, you know, and it comes from
the Cold War and it's a dangerous place,
but the real issue becomes what is, what
is the u s is strength has always been,
not that it's power comes from the barrel
of a gun in the u s has its influence
innovation,
but mostly it's a beacon of hope where
you can come here and if you got the
stuff and you got the metal,
you might just be a millionaire.
That is something that
resonates throughout the
entire world and always has.
I wanted to ask you this because you've
got some experience in the Middle East.
What do you think is happening with all
these different places with I saw your
radio with Egypt.
I think it's a thing and it's a human
thing and I'll tell you what I think
mostly most of all,
I think that you heard a lot of analysts
and professionals and people who follow
this stuff and people who are
so called experts and the,
I used to always hear something that
they used to always say this democracy's
not synonymous with Islam.
You'd hear that all the time.
And I think what this proves
is that democracy, and let me,
let me define democracy,
that the desire for representative
government, let's just take that,
the, the life, liberty and
the pursuit of happiness.
I just let me pursue whatever it is.
Those constantly being
able to speak my mind,
being able to petition my government,
being able to say something against
my government, being able to,
to all the things we take for granted.
Those are human rights and,
and they are not, they are not American
rights. They are human rights. And,
and this proves that you can say whatever
you want about Islam or anything else
or any other religion. Human beings
want a better life for their children.
Human beings would choose
to have representative
government over a dictatorship
like Hosni Mubarak or,
or a dictatorship like the,
the royal family essentially
is in Saudi Arabia.
Don't tell me any human
being wants to live that way.
I find it very inspiring that one
man and Tunisia lit himself on fire.
You want to talk about a ripple effect
lit himself on fire because they took
away his license. I believe he was selling
fruit and he said, enough is enough.
He was so desperate and he said, I'm going
to make an example. This is my protest.
You want it, you want to take everything
from me, I'll light myself on fire.
And I don't think that's a good move. But
that was a spark that caused that, that,
that, that said, that said, we
don't have to be afraid anymore.
We don't have to beat,
we don't have to cringe.
And and saying that
these governments like,
like Egypt in both places where they have
with a military and secret police come
in and do some pretty awful things
to you that takes real guts.
So I think it's a real,
I think this is a, um,
an incredible time in the sense
that the Middle East is changing.
It really is changing and it's
the really is the Internet nation.
Of course it is, but you can't
keep information away from people.
You can fool the people sometimes
you can fool all the people.
Sometimes it can be some of
the people all of the time.
You can't fool all the people all the
time. Except North Korea who said that?
I believe that was Abe
Lincoln, right? Yeah.
Who knows what the fuck ain't really said.
You know, Abraham Lincoln was a racist.
I'm just trying to encourage black people
to move to South America because they
wouldn't get along with white page.
It's actually more complicated than that,
but I think it's more complicated
than that. Of course he is sweet.
He's slept with dudes. Do. Why is he slept
with dudes? They slept in bed together.
Stay warm. Wow. This is no big deal.
You got to do what you gotta do, man.
You live in fucking prairie pioneer days
out of speedos and you're gonna call me
gay. What's an Abe Lincoln? A wrestler.
He was very strong. He was about six,
four and he was very,
very strong.
They said he used to be able to hold an
acts like one of those big butch having
acts out for like longer than anybody
else with his arms straight like that.
He was a real wirey strong dude.
Straight with his on what a weird
competition that it's back of the day.
They'd get all this is hopscotch
hard things, right? Like you know,
let's see a whole hind quarter
of a mule up above your head.
Now you know how to be a first guy
back then to try to wrestle a bear too.
I always think about that stuff. Who
wrote a bull who said, hey, you know what?
Throw a testicle essential on that bull.
I'm going to get up on him and see how
long is that originated and is that an
American tradition? Well, I
probably started in smelled Spain.
They were like knocking like a ride and
I'm just going to kill it with a sword.
It's pretty bad ass. Yeah. You know
what bothers me about that though, man,
is a bunch of other dudes helping
out. Oh well, because there's,
because you know the Madeira Bull,
I think it's called the Madeira evil.
Hemingway wrote a book called death in
the afternoon and he kind of takes each,
brings you through what a
what a fighting bulls about.
You're not allowed in Spain, you're not
in. And some of you guys listening to his,
I just check this out.
You're not allowed in Spain to
approach a fighting bull on foot.
You must approach it on a bicycle,
motorcycle or car. You know why?
Because Bulls figure out the way you move.
And if you,
if they watch you walking around
all the time and running around,
when you put them in a, in a, in, in
the, in the ring with the Matador,
that manager doesn't have a chance
because they figured you out.
The first time [inaudible] ever sees a
human being on two feet by law in Spain
is when he's put out there in front
of that matador. And by the way,
they got rubbed out there,
got to rub his eyes with pepper to keep
them a little bit blind. They gotta,
they gotta pick a deal is coming there
and stab him in the back so he can't lift
his head. So he's got these
spears in is, it's pretty brutal.
They've got to disable that bull
before on the human being has any shot,
any shot at fighting,
it didn't shut and they still die.
They still die when they say,
when you're a matador in Spain,
that's where you are. Forget
girls, forget music for a house.
Your life is about the bowl fog.
Is there a lot of money and being
an amount of door, um, there's a,
there's huge glory and money and you're,
you're a national hero if you're good.
And by the way, it's probably like
the UFC start with like, you know,
guys were fighting with blunt horns and
then all the way up to the big show, but,
but um,
but you know,
when they used to pit bulls with bears
gives you used to always win. Oh,
I would say to the bowl. I would say
every time there is so strong there are,
there's utilizers touched one. You ever
been on one? If you've written a book. No,
but I've touched, I've been to
settle rich. Same thing sorta.
So Lisa, when we were doing fear factory,
we made people ride bulls one day.
It was the scariest it's ever
been. Uh, any, any day of filming.
This was one day where I felt like we
crossed the line. I was like, what?
Are you doing? Dangerous. They are not.
They're like, they're bold. They were,
this was the, their argument. These are
training bowls. They're not as aggressive.
What does that bowl, no,
he's a fucking training.
But I didn't know you were a poet by
meter where the bull whispers he around.
I love when people think
they know what an animal is.
I love when they have Christ strand.
It's tiger won't bite you.
You were talking about
it to me in the kitchen.
We're talking about that grizzly
trained bear, that tour the, uh,
I think it was his trainer, his
brother or cousin, her cousin.
And it killed him in a couple of seconds.
It was horrible.
So weird because that's a 1500 pound bear,
grabbed a hold of an [inaudible]
in a lazy way. And the poor guy,
I guess he's pretty aggressive.
I mean obviously the guy must've so
scary what it represented to the bear.
But he was represented some sort of a
threat. Well apparently though he's,
he was doing what he's supposed to do
and I guess the guy didn't have his arms
up or something and they bear ended up
grabbing onto his neck and his instinct
took over and he said, oh, I'm
going to shake you to death,
which is Tara's supposed to
have your arms up. I don't know.
I don't got to stick them up, pose my bear
wrestling. And I'm a white belt still.
I'm still so what do you think the fuck
is going on with all these mass deaths?
There's a million fish die
in the Redondo Beach Harbor.
All these animals that have died and
birds that are falling from the sky,
I think, cause you don't see, I
don't know. But I would imagine,
I would imagine we have a very polluted
at a environment and probably is a
combination of all those chemicals in
the environment and chemicals are being
made.
You know,
we're very good at coming
up with synthetic material
and synthetic chemicals.
And what we're probably not as good
at and what the FDA could never do is
figuring out how all these chemicals
when put together interact or how they,
what they do to, to, to Mitoplasma and if
that's even that, like using big words,
but like what they do to our bodies,
uh, on prolonged, uh, you know,
when we drink them, when we're around
them all the time. Look at your house.
All these new products that come out
that have huge advertising campaigns,
they're probably very
safe in on their own.
What happens when you mix six of
them in the perfect combination?
What is that doing to your genetic?
What's Wifi to, who knows what the fuck?
We're always a,
we know that sonar gets in the way of
Whales Migrate Migratory Flux Whales Up,
right? Yeah. So, so, um, uh, it's,
it's always this constant dance of how,
you know, in China now what they're doing.
I think it's really interesting.
There's a lot of the architects
when they plan these cities,
they're building gardens on the roofs
so you can plant food and grow your own
food on the roof of your building.
You know, China, so self sustainable,
there's a billion people there.
They don't, they don't import food.
They make their own food,
which is, which is again, very,
which is a very recent development
for China. It's pretty amazing. Yeah.
Do that with a billion people. But when
you do that, you've got to eat bugs. Well,
we're getting better,
but we're getting better and better
at figuring out ways to grow plants,
for example,
that don't need pesticides that are,
that are much higher in protein
and different nutrients. Sure.
But then you're getting weird because
things are genetically monitored than
Monsanto owns the dark side. You know,
Monsanto, scariest. Fuck, what's that?
It's a thing when you say it's fine if
you want to cross pollinate to wheat, uh,
the strains. But when you take
the, the gene from a jellyfish,
put it in a strawberry so
that my strawberry doesn't
freeze when I'm shipping it
across the country. That's a little weird
man. When you're, when you're, you know,
when all of a sudden my oranges are
square cause it's easier to pack them.
Well have you seen all the
wikileaks documents leading
to a genetically modified
foods?
So they're trying to push it all across
the world are trying to push into the
and the countries and there
they're putting imposing
sanctions on countries that
they do. Also what you can, you can,
if you plant one field over here,
it's genetically modified and cross
pollinates flies in there. Yeah.
And then they sue the,
those people and those people have
to either close up their farm or,
well it becomes a fucking disaster
I think. I think, you know,
I'm a capitalist and all that,
but I think that we are paying,
we have to be very careful with how
everything is becoming these conglomerates
and how things are becoming so corporate.
Look at radio.
Every time I travel this country,
you and I both traveled the country.
Everything is so homogenous. We've,
we've, we've, we've paid a price.
You people want efficiency. But why
in the world when I go to most cities,
can I only eat at a,
at a corporate chain?
Is there a rabbi I'm surrounded by?
I was going to say clear channel.
I'm surrounded by, by, by, um, by
beige walls. Whether it's Kmart,
there's no continuum. There's
no like, history. Nobody
feels connected to anything.
Everything around me is, everybody's
trying to sell me something I don't need.
And, and it's, it robs
every city of its character.
It's like the death of the American city.
What happened at main street with the
mom and pop shops. I want that boiler,
but it's,
but,
but these cities used to all have
it and I understand that progress.
Small places to get that.
I was dealing with large volume of people,
small places like that become impact.
It's an offshoot of globalism
and it was priced. We had to pay,
we'll probably swing back,
but we pay a price.
When you think you can see in speed,
what do you think about all these people
that believe that you know and if you
read almost every ancient religion has
some story of a great apocalypse or a
great catastrophe and almost every
religion has some story about a previous
existing society that was advanced and
that was almost wiped off the face of the
earth. You know when you hear shit about
all these animals dying and fish dying,
this sounds like religious scripture.
How fucking crazy would it be if we
all really have been all through this
before,
if human beings have literally gotten
to the point of where we are now,
like this sophisticated,
if we died off today,
how much of this shit would be
around in 10,000 years or so,
how much would we be able to find and
recognize anything that that isn't steel?
I think that is great.
I think it's a great direction.
I do think that that was the answer
may lie in somewhere in the area.
If I were to answer that question
and what I don't know, but,
but I think that there is, there is a, um,
human beings are the, are still faced
with the same problems as human beings.
So whether or not I was
living 3000 years ago, the,
the big questions that
one has to rest with
that answer the question of what
am I doing here? Who am I really?
What am I supposed to do?
What does this all mean?
Those are questions you can never
run from. And so within that context,
I think we'd be still, we'd still
be trying to answer those questions.
We'd still be trying to go
beyond our biology shore.
So be trying to get more pleasure than
pain would still be out trying to figure
out how to keep our children alive
with better food. So I think end,
but we'd be competing with
resources and we'd still have wars.
So I think in a way it makes sense
that we'd keep repeating ourselves.
This is the human experience.
What I'm saying is,
do you think that it's ever
gotten to this point before?
When you look at some of the structures
that exist that are unexplained there
many, many thousands of years old,
especially with the pyramids go.
I mean unexplained in the fact that
they're not exactly sure how they put that
all together.
There's a lot of theories and there's
also old dynasty in new dynasty and
there's old kingdom,
a new kingdom.
There's a lot of structures
that they believe are far,
far older than the traditional. We
thought it like the, the pyramid of Giza,
the Great Pyramid of any, well, I think,
I think what separates human beings
from animals as far as I know,
is that we have imagination and that
we seem to be always moving toward the
limits of our imagination.
But what freaks me out is there's a bunch
of shit that they can't figure out how
it all got done.
And one of them is dogs.
Do you know dogs are a great
mystery. You know, when you,
when you look into the DNA of dogs,
it turns out that all of
them descend from wolves.
They thought it was going to be a bunch
of different wild canids and different,
they're all from all from fucking
actually domesticated wolf. So, and they,
we don't know how the fuck that was done
thousands and thousands of years ago.
We do know that people have
always bread their animals,
whether they're horses or whatever.
Sure. Even farm animals to eat.
They've read them so long ago to be,
goes back so far that it
literally predate society.
And that's why it's squirrely.
Cause you're talking about 10,000,
15,000 maybe even deeper and deeper
into the history of breeding dogs.
Yeah. And I think at the answer maybe
also is the fact that they're, this,
this world is way more, uh,
what much older than ours.
We are probably much older.
Human beings are probably much,
history is one thing,
but real human history is another.
And, and you also want to evolution.
I always think about that.
It's what's interesting to
me is like, is it, if indeed,
you know, there's a lot of sense. I
said, well we, we've all from apes,
chimps or whatever it might
be. Um, it, it, it's, you
know, people say, well, we're,
we kind of seem to stop the evolving
physically then if that's the case,
didn't we? No. We moved in
a different direction. Look,
the doubling of the human brain sizes,
the giant,
the biggest mystery and
entire fossil record.
And that's what changed us from
this, this, this, you know,
beetle eating fucking freak monkey to
human beings and whatever the fuck caused
it. I wonder why he believes
it was mushrooms. You know,
some people believe it
was the throwing arm.
Some people believe it was fish
that we started eating food.
But that doesn't make sense to me
because bears are stupid. It's fuck,
and they eat a lot. But it goes
beyond that. I'm saying why, you know,
chimps have always been chimps. Human
beings have continued to evolve, uh,
just, uh, at least an hour.
Well, you know, we'll see in
that in we are, we do really
amazing things. Know I joke around about
people being from monkeys and chimps,
but the real lineage is there's a bunch
of different primates that evolved next
to each other.
For some reason we evolved in a far more
sophisticated way than all the rest of
them. And in the sense that we're
always trying to go beyond that,
which we can measure and we're always
contemplating what that would be.
How do you, how would you
ever measure, for example,
the fact that a great go out an old Mozart
or Bach Sonata make some people feel
profoundly sad and overjoyed
the same time? Why do we
even have that stuff? Yeah,
it sounds good to our ears,
but think about the genius of Great
Jazz like Louis Armstrong, Chaz.
Like why in the world would
that guy, well, I'm just saying,
I'm just saying I'm using it.
I'm using it as an art form.
Like why in the world would we come up
with these brass horns and playing all
those things that are sort of what
we stay alive for. It's interesting.
It's like what are we supposed
to be doing with that?
What are we supposed to be doing
with the fact that most religions,
all religions talk about well, love each
other. That's the most important thing.
Love each other. And
then, and then by the way,
what do you do with that relationship?
What are you trying to
make the world better?
What do you do when you come
together? Uh, as, as social animals.
Why and and what, what is,
what is the point of that?
That's the big question that we're
always dealing with it. I think it seems,
if there's no point,
it seems that the point is to
enjoy it and to be nice to people.
That seems to be the point.
The idea, if you're temporary,
you're a temporary being and all your
descendants are temporary beings.
We just keep evolving in a tide
of everchanging temporary beings.
Then the only point is just be nice,
but then why?
But then we'd just be then I guess
be nice. How Fun. Write it out.
Let's see what's next. Is there a creative
group of people that were affected by,
you know, thousands of what do you think?
There's anything to be said though?
The going beyond that in the sense that
are we supposed to evolve and continue
to understand more and more until we,
until her [inaudible] so short.
It's like, it's the same thing when we
talked about before the human experience.
What I'm saying is we keep jumping on each
other's shoulders. Right? Yeah. So, so,
so, you know, even Newton
said that, he said, I've,
I've stood on the ice to it
on the shoulder of giants.
You guys all talk about me being, I
invented calculus, not bad Isaac who said,
by the way, as big as accomplishment,
it was lifelong celibacy. Not, not,
not calculus.
He was like my biggest compliment.
It wasn't that I invented the concept
of gravity and spatial relationships.
It's a, that I was celibate my whole
life. That's what cool. Yeah. I was like,
really? You have one chick sucked his
dick would have ruined everything,
but did didn't have to be the father
of modern physics, modern science. But,
but he said, but, but that's what
I'm saying is that we've all,
we all stand on each other's shoulders.
It seems that we are evolving in our
understanding of more and more of how even
animals think. And of course, you know,
we're certainly evolving
everything point to this evolution.
I hope I always have said that.
I think that we're probably becoming
something through technology and the human
beings are probably just
like a caterpillar that
becomes a butterfly but just
doesn't know what it's doing.
While it's doing it.
All our natural instincts
towards materialism and
greed and selfishness and and
you know,
all these monkey instincts that we have
leftover perhaps working in a natural
order to move us towards
this ultimate goal, like
some sort of technological
we're making for example.
I mean that's where Kurt's well
believes. He believes that, you know,
it's going to be some sort of an
artificial technology and artificial
intelligence that we can download our
consciousness into and that you will exist
forever in perpetrate in this, you know,
artificial environment. How does, yeah,
there you go. That's a class. Does
that mean it means the matrix?
I mean you're talking craziness.
Not only now you're talking about if
you can duplicate your consciousness,
you could duplicate it in an infinite
amount of times and it will exist.
Not here in this physical space,
but it will exist in some sort of cyber
world where you will constantly be in
like a a replaying life now
that in an infinite number of,
and not only that we will ultimately end,
truly be connected and our experience
will be, we are, but we are now.
It's just,
it's in a weird way and I think the reason
why it's set up in a weird way as to
encourage competition, you know,
the thing that bugs people the most,
the things that is losing, you know, the
thing, losing anything, losing a person,
losing, you know, losing your job, losing,
losing, losing a fight, losing in a game.
It's frustrating for us.
We're designed for competition.
Some people so much so that you beat
them at pool and they get mad at you.
You never ever been around that
guy. Beat him at pool. But, but see,
I like to ask the next question though.
Like losing the defining that really
actually I think in some ways not isn't
just losing your power in a way.
Losing his to be left alone in a way to
be sure you're not special and another
form of what we believe you.
And so I think that's ultimately
why people hate losing so much.
It's that memory of feeling alone.
It's that.
But there's also a strong desire for
competition among, amongst most people.
How many comics do you know that when
they see someone else get something,
something big, they actually get upset
that it's not happening to them. I do.
You're the only successful comic I've
ever heard comics not talk bad about you.
I think that's ridiculous.
People have talked bad about me.
Lots of people are not really not
comics. Go talk to mark Marin. Nah,
you don't hear comics say bad
things about you. I've never,
and I know what the point I'm
making is that you're right. I mean,
for the most part I'm, I'm, I'm
saying that you're right. People when,
when somebody actually does well,
if it's a comic they get,
they get a lot of times. Yeah, a lot
of times different deserve sometimes.
Especially when you're young and scrappy
and you're all coming up in the same
order. You know, like you're all like 22,
23 and one of these 22 year old guys gets,
uh,
some radio show where he's the morning
Dj guy and like, all fuck, you know,
he's the morning Dj guy had Katie la now
or whatever. You know what I mean? Like,
and then all of a sudden you like,
dudes feel like that could have been them.
Sure. You know? And then what they
have to understand also, by the way,
is that this is not a linear process.
This,
this world is made of a whole bunch
of nonlinear luck and mathematics.
And all you say is that because you're
a very experienced guy and you've gone
through so many things in so many
different projects and so, I mean you've,
you've, you've gone through the
Tour de force of, of television.
He did a sketch show and mad TV.
You've done family shows on, on,
on those Warner brothers networks,
right?
You've done fucking for everything you
did sex in the city. You know, you've done
so many different things.
You've really had a broad like view
of the whole entertainment scene done.
A lot of people just don't get, they
don't get that. So when you're young,
especially like all you know is, I want
to fucking make it. I got to make it.
I gotta pay my bills. I got
to your fucking freaking
night shit. He got it. Fuck.
Why didn't he remember that? By the
way? I remember being terrified.
I wasn't gonna make it. I remember
thinking, that's not an option for me.
Like it wasn't an option for us
to be working well, all of us,
I think anybody who actually became a
comic, you had to deal with the fact that,
man, if I put my eggs in this basket,
this shit my turn turn out terrible.
How might just live in rotten eggs
in the air. Nothing. It's terrifying.
It's completely terrifying. But
my point is that like, you know,
like in show business like that,
the whole idea of like pursuing it and
like go and after it is absolutely of
course uncertain,
but it has to be uncertain.
It's uncertain because that's the only
way we're like real queer adventure.
Creativity comes from something.
It blossoms out of that uncertain.
If you knew it was going to happen
and you had it all plotted out,
it'd be boring as fuck.
When you got that for you and it's pouring
for that and you'd have to do drugs,
you'd have to start doing coke.
I think that's why people like when they
take a Gig for the money, for example,
like they go, well, you're going to be $7
million to do a talk show, a game show.
They really do pay a price for that. Yes,
you, you, you got to keep the uncertainty.
Dude.
I paid a price for fear factor for sure.
I love doing that show and it was a lot
of fun and I loved making all that money
and I'm happy I did it,
but man,
there was a lot of days that I didn't
want to do that and I thought this is
hokey or this is silly or this is
like God, this is, it became a job,
which is nothing wrong with revolve
respectable. We don't make fun of horse.
We all, we were all horse in some ways.
We all hoard before is what I'm saying.
Sure. And but what am I, my whole point
about the whole competition thing about,
I think that all of that,
it's all set up that way on purpose and
then like show Biz competition and in
the standup comedy competition, even
martial arts competition, like these guys,
when they started trash talking
each other on the Internet,
you know how I look at it when I look
at like two fighters are about to trash
talk each other. I look at it like
birds that are squawking at each other.
Like one birds is on the fence and then
the other bird like fucking flaps its
wings. It gets close to it. It's like
this natural thing that they're doing,
like they have to do this to in
order to motivate them to be great,
in order to push them all to the next
level, you have to feel the jealousy.
Madison who said, you know, I
always wondered who I leave,
was talking, talking to,
and he said I'm the greatest.
And then I realized one day he was
talking to himself. Oh yeah. He said,
he said to train, cause you know, I'm,
I'm scared to death every time
I step in that ring. But I,
but I get myself worked up
and by the time I'm in there,
I believe what I'm saying am I,
that's the saddest thing in the world
at Muhammad Ali is the way he is now.
That's a great note. And that, you know,
it's Parkinson's and he has
trauma related Parkinson.
What's amazing also is that he doesn't
hide it from the world. They'd get,
the guy holds the torch, the
Olympics. He just gets up in front of,
everybody hears me. You know, it's weird
listening to Mike Tyson talk these days.
If you heard Mike Tyson talk,
I haven't just got a reality show now.
He got an interview with this
reality show on, on pigeons.
But he got interviewed at this, uh, there
was a showtime boxing match recently. No.
Yeah. Well the paper view match
between Miguel Cotto and um, uh,
we're caught in Majorca
and it was a good fight.
And they interviewed the Tyson Kodo. Did.
He stopped him in the last round. Um,
and they, they talked to Tyson
about it and Tyson like, you know,
it was like he was laboring to talk,
you know, and I was listening to him.
I was like, wow, maybe he's just
tired and maybe they caught, yeah,
you might have been high as fuck.
That's true because catch me,
I might look like a braid down. Nice.
Mostly if ever met a fight. You know what?
I don't have to do commentary.
God,
I love going to fights when I don't have
to do commentary because these guys,
when we, whenever we go to the
UFC, Brian and Orient Joey,
if these guys take pot cookies and get
blue grieved. So they're sitting up.
Last time was acid.
So they're sitting up in the stands.
I kind of have in the fucking time. Joey
Diaz has does the commentary, right?
Joey Diaz,
just like in the middle of fights,
he'll start just rants and raves about
this happened and that happened. So Ben,
especially if somebody gets knocked out
or somebody gets submitted, I don't,
what the fuck did I tell you?
A dog, he'll get up and go cry.
But I don't get to see that anymore.
I do, you know? Do you know what,
did you really truly feel comfortable
calling a fight in the UFC?
When did it really start to Gel? Because
it just comes out of you now. Um,
you know, the first couple of times I
was self conscious about it. You know,
it's weird you're trying to do a good job,
but you don't want to be,
there's a lot of ego involved in
commentary that's very unpleasant.
Like you hear people talking too much
about themselves or what take yourself
what they would do. Well, I have to,
first of all, I'm completely illegitimate.
I mean,
I'm a brown belt in Jujitsu and I fought
and some taekwondo and some kickboxing,
but I've never found any MMA fights at
all. So I, I, what am I going to say? Oh,
I could do better than this. You
know what I mean? It's silly. I'm,
I'm completely objective about it.
But I,
it took a while for me to be
comfortable with like how I should,
you know,
what I should talk about and what I
shouldn't talk about and when to talk,
when not to talk. And you know,
it had a, how to like get,
be as respectful as possible but yet be
as objective and analytical as possible
about what's happening,
you know,
so you have to walk a fine line between
critiquing fighters and criticizing them
or a obsessing patterns that you see
in movement and critiquing behavior and
training regiments and shit like that.
So it's, it's, it's tricky. It's tricky,
but I always do it from a place of
respect and I always do it from a place of
as, as objective as I'm capable. You're
very good at doing, it's fun to do.
I didn't Goldie's is,
is a poet that, yeah,
it's just amazing what a lot of people
don't know. It's like they'll say, Goldie,
Phil, you've got to fill
here. Got to fill here.
They'll say they'd say that
to our headsets. So Goldie,
we'll start just going off about
this fucking arena that we're in.
That was built in 18 fucking 12 and he's
off the top of his head and band aids
and he just does it make perfectly,
you know,
1912 he might've stumbled once in the
thousand fights that we wrote those lines
out and they're just perfect.
Sometimes he doesn't say the correct
thing when it comes to like the technique
or something like that,
but that's okay because I can
correct him and he just trying
to get things going.
Like he's just trying to,
you know who's you know who he is by the
way. I don't know if you've ever seen,
you know,
it was the best improviser I've ever
seen in my life and a guy who can take a
topic and do 30 minutes of stand up
on it and do whatever is Adam Carolla.
Oh yeah. Evil rambled pro. That's why
he's so good as a Pocho a podcast host,
that guy, you give them a
subject, here's the thing. Okay.
All for you having your coffee and he'll
just like have some goes off 20 minute
rant about what's wrong with like,
you know,
he did something about twist ties
about twist ties. Like, well,
what was it like twist ties.
Like how strong are these things?
And they should be you.
Like,
she'd cover up those soldiers in Iraq
with twist ties. I mean, he just,
he's amazing.
It's coming up with just like free
form and like entire jokes I said,
and we got off. I go, I got,
we did a movie together and I go and
we were on set and I go, you know what?
I said, I've decided you're, you're,
you might be the best in the
world at what you do. And he goes,
what do you mean? I said, I think
you're the best improviser and a good,
best guy I've ever seen at Improv.
The way you do your Improv. I'm never,
I think you're the best in the world.
He goes, oh, I don't know. I go,
somebody has got to be
the best. So, um, you're,
you're getting the trophy I'm good
at. So he goes like this. He goes,
so apparently this is the podcast,
next thing, cause you know, you know,
I know I like that guy,
Brian cow guy.
And he told me I might be the best
improviser in the world and I thought,
you know why not? So I got home and I
looked at my wife and I was like, hey,
how come? No, I don't
smell any pot. Roast wise,
my dick in your mouth for crying saying
I'm the best guy in the world and Improv.
And he's like, recognize any Brian
counts. Said it. So it's true. He's a guy,
he's really found success with this whole
podcast format. He's also a great guy.
He's a great guy. Good guy.
He's an interesting dude.
He's really into cars, man.
He's got the dope. Who's on
Raj? Man, is he very good.
Did you ever box with him? No,
but I've heard guys who fight like guys,
he's actually a ringer.
You'll get in a ring. And it
really, it was a real, I believe it.
He's good at everything.
He's a great carpenter.
He like fucking remodels his house and
shit builds additions on his own real
American. He has a real Alec Baldwin
read far before he went crazy. And, and,
and this guy might be my Adam Carolla
has the dopest garage mountain.
He's got like one of those garages. Yeah.
But I'm, mine was built for a TV show.
You got to pee pee.
But I'm Carolla's garage is like a,
he's got like a fucking Ferrari there.
A like a classic BMW m three.
He's got a Mustang back there.
He's got a Lamborghini back there.
I think he's kind of like
a classic Lamborghini.
It was just like really fucking into
like machines and cars and shit. What's,
what's going on with Kevin Smith?
What's this talk on top of? He was,
he said he wanted to get together and do
a podcast and he said, uh, we should uh,
smoke pot. Talk about news radio. I'm
like, fuck yeah, I would love to a man.
So I messaged him, but when you get,
and here's the thing, when people say,
how come nobody moves Mitch Book with
me, Buck, I'm not on Twitter all day.
I tried to go on and post
things when I have time. And,
but a lot of times I'm fucking busy.
And when you have like,
I think now I'm up to 283,000
bitch, what am I looking? Just because
you don't have that many, excuse me.
283,982 so almost 284,000 there's no
way I can keep up with the replies.
There's the, if you don't look at it
for an hour, there's 1700 replies.
And so what do you do? Do you do read
them all? I can't. I don't have the time.
It's impossible.
Some of those people listen,
bitch got to earn them shit.
My Dad says he's not.
He doesn't have a podcast.
How's that going to get so famous?
Going to be cool though.
If you could give them like,
I'll give you 50,000 people on Twitter.
Yeah.
And then all of sudden they'd be
getting your goofy ass. I hate cats.
What's wrong with this guy? This new
IPAD by the way? Fucking awesome.
I think you'll use it more.
Why they using the market as a camera?
The camera's shit is so bad ass fucking
sitting there doing facetimes and shit
like that were 13 year old girl,
little girl looking at my face.
You could,
we could transplant your brain into a
13 year old lesbian so easily. It's hot.
The camera's bad ass. You
are loving it. I'm loving it.
It's at the other one was good but then
the no camera thing just really made me
never want to use it that much. Really?
Yeah cause that was a big part at all man.
I only use it for watching things like
when I was getting tattooed I use it to
watch TV shows and I use it to for reading
books. Yeah know he's a friend. What?
What's that iPad? Yeah. I don't have one.
I'm just going to get the air book cause
I traveled but do I need an iPad? Yeah,
that's an Arabic. You don't need one. This
is a little Mac book. Little tiny arrow.
It's a light light pussy bro.
I get a 17 inch and I carry
that shit over my shoulder.
I don't even bother putting the
backpack on. Dude. I do squats.
I do kettle bells on a regular sun step.
One time you said to a
bus full of fighters?
I remember it was like
the four back in the UFC.
Literally when Randy called to
our foot view to our Belfour,
it's like back in those
days like 20 gunner,
we were in Tennessee or
baton rouge or something.
And I remember walking into the venue,
remember that like how,
how ghetto it was back in
the day like just and Randy,
we were actually that
anyway, but um, you go, uh,
they were talking about training
techniques and you were like,
I like to get into horse dance and uh,
put my boss inside my
body and read Nietzsche.
I think Emmanuel steward
was that like be like,
everybody's like all these fighters,
no sense here.
But they all look through like this.
They're like,
oh is he saying what he's saying?
Cause you weren't really that famous yet.
Really?
Like I like to get in the horse stance,
pushed my balls and my body and read,
read Nietzsche.
Everyone's like see fucking serious.
Cause you were kind of squat and they
didn't look, didn't laugh at me at all,
but I got into a squat position too.
I've gone to that horse dance.
I was fucking done. There was no room
for humor in those early UFC. Nah Man,
that was just,
I was,
I was also the post fight interview
or it wasn't a commentator,
so no one got to see my sense of,
you know, when we were with tank and,
and we're all those guys. And you
were just like, be be careful.
Don't be a jackass around tank.
I don't know what he might tank
will implode your skull speech.
Well just beat your ass. You know,
like, you know Brian don't be it.
Don't be like, Hey, thank
hang, hang Handley. I'm going
to tweak your nose tank.
We'll put you to sleep. He
puts me to sleep, go to jail,
ignore normal, kill you,
kill you.
He might definitely changed the way you
look at the world or shaking his hand
and, and, and it felt, I've never
felt the hand that strongest is,
he was just a burger.
How about thinking about dude's like,
we were talking about how bad ass mayhem
as you were fucking around with mayhem.
And uh, I said, well, I want to watch the,
show you a video of who some are
Paul Horace submitting. Ma'Am.
Just think that someone can do that to
a guy as good as Ma'am as good and as
strong as mammals. There's just
levels, level levels upon levels.
I'm a bad balloon. That guy's a silver
back. That's how it is. You know,
I'm a Saluki engine.
The first dude that fucking stumble
across gorillas because that did happen by
the way, as far as western humans
that, you know, as far as white people,
that's right. That, that like they were,
the gorillas were a myth until like
the 18 hundreds, right. In Indonesia,
a guy had a woke up, uh,
uh, male, uh, orangutan up,
woke them up and think fleet flipped
out and grabbed him by the hair.
It got kind of long hair thicken and
he's grabbing my hair and just, yeah,
Yang and,
and scalped him,
they took all his just rip and
Scout. I'm like, he freaked out.
I pulled this a hair off and,
and, and, and then ran off
into the trees. Oh my God.
So he had no scalp. That's
right. So what they do,
they have to like skin graft was
head are fucked in Indonesia.
You know, I would just die
of staph infection today. I
am surprised like, you know,
I think in the crazy thing
is gorilla to the biggest,
but they don't even eat meat.
They're all vegetarian. That's right.
It's called genetics. My friend. I
knew. Watch them and watch those grills.
You can stand right next to him because
there's it's plex. Watch them wrestle.
All they do when they're
little is wrestle.
All they do is roll around and they have
arm drags. Duck unders. I'm not kidding.
Real. It locks guillotines I swear to
God they put you in their guard. I swear.
So I'm telling you that,
that the man who invented you too.
It's just hitting and Gracie
Helio. Well, sort of. I mean,
there was Japanese Raf scores first
of course, but he, he, you know,
after he could find a helio and Carlos,
I would,
I wouldn't be surprised if one day
they were watching gorillas row,
watch them play. It is there. So
they're, they're the perfect wrestlers.
They're so efficient for wrestling.
They're so efficient.
It's just so weird that they're
so big and that the plants, why?
Because a silverback is not six feet tall,
maybe six feet tall and weighs 600
pounds. Fat Free, ladies and gentlemen,
no fed on this giant fucking monstrous
arms and hope. What does all that for?
Is it all just to keep things from fucking
with it? It must be, I don't know, man.
It's just, cause they don't kill any,
they don't really swing through trees.
They're just, and they're not really
aggressive. They have little dicks. Yep.
And they have little dicks. I have a
bigger dick than a 600 pound gorilla.
She's a Samson. So, uh, let's think
about that though. 600 pounds,
that's a, that's a lot of
weight. And then, and then
there's the polar bear. Yeah.
Which would eat a gorilla.
Yeah. What the fuck do you
think a polar bear could
eat a gorilla? Yeah. Really?
Yeah. Oh, what do I think so?
I don't know. I would have ever done
that. They 15 to 16 to 1700 pounds.
Is that what a polar bears? Some of
the little girls because he got down,
but they stand. They stand
10 feet or higher. They're,
they're bigger than a basketball. Go to
a basketball hoop, try to touch the rim.
And they're bigger than that. When they
stand in their court on their hind legs.
Um, yeah. They take down,
they take down things like elk
with their mouths. Uh, yeah.
You will kill the whales. You ever seen
them eat pilot whales through the ice?
I have no doubt. The polar bears have big
penises. I Dunno, it's a good question,
but they'll kick the shit out
of aggression. Rock solid.
Question, question Brian.
Thank you. Hold that question for a
second. We'll put that on the wall.
Polar bears are scary as fuck. If you're
in Alaska, if you see one, you better run.
Big Carnival. Biggest biggest land
carnivore actively targets human beings,
human beings,
they will make a beeline for you is a
terrifying story that I read once about
these guys that were in a boat and the
boat hit an iceberg and the boat starts
to sink.
So they sent out a distress signal and
they climbed off the boat onto an ice
shelf. You heard a story? Yeah, I know.
All of us. There's a few researchers,
I forget the number, but there was
more than three terrible story and uh,
this polar bear saw them and kept diving
off one ice sculpture to the next,
getting closer and closer sizing them
up until finally he was on the one ice
sculpture, jumping around. There was
screaming the yelling, the polar bear.
I didn't give a fuck. He's like, hmm,
make yourself hard to swap
them to eat some you bridges.
And he came over and he was on the ice
ice sculpture of the Ice Island right
next to them, jumped in the
water, got on their side,
walked calmly up to the first guy
he'd get ahold of. They scrambled.
Everybody stumbled over each other trying
to get out of the way. Grabs a guy,
kills him right there.
Instantly grabs his limp body,
jumps off the ice,
ice island into the water,
swims over to the other one, just starts
eating. I'm right in front of them.
And so he ate that one guy
and then help came and help.
Came in the next boat came when
the, the, you know, this distressed.
It was answered by the
time they got there.
This guy was just rib cage popping
out of his fucking his jacket.
I don't want to, I'm not really
interested in die that way. Thank you.
Cause you're not doing anything. That's
a bear. Good luck. And a polar bear.
Polar bears and fucking ocean. Do
they grab you by the neck? And I did.
They just shake a couple of times,
I guess sometimes.
Sometimes they just start eating.
You start eating you from the bikes up.
Like the guy from grizzly bear,
seven minute audio tape time didn't go on
and go some eggs. Oh, those are my feet.
My feet least that shit doesn't
my calves. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
My Thei just taking
chunks out of your thigh.
Ruthless. That youtube video of the woman
got too close to the polar bear's cave.
Oh yeah. And it breaks her
leg. Yep. Brought her in Hana
soccer. Yeah. They're mean.
They're also fast. Well they have to be
there live in fucking the frozen north.
What a crazy place to live. They like
to clean up agents of the frozen north.
You can't put a baby polar bear
or even a smaller polar bear,
like an adolescent polar bear into
a cage with a big bear is what?
It'll eat it. Oh yeah. Jack females
will keep those there. Their cubs,
they'll dealt Dell run away from a male.
A male will chase a female in her cubs
for two days trying to eat those cubs.
She's fucking so I'll follow up.
Female running and keeping her cubs going
to get away from a male who sees them
and says, I want to eat your babies
babe. Fuck. Cause she goes, guys,
we've got to run. Let's run now. But why
is he still chasing us? I'm tired. Mommy.
Shut up. This is, that's the school
of hard knocks by the way. Yeah.
You think and you know Anelli both
fucking cubs to, they won't just eat one,
let the other one free.
No,
he's going to kill that one and went out
after the next one or the other one is,
you know, yeah, they have to
store up. They have the store.
I'm just not doing a thing.
She's got to just go, ah,
Randy Kaltura asked me
to go hunting with them.
I'm going to go hunting with Randy
coture arts and we were going to go bear
hunting, but I'm like, I want
to eat a bear man. I don't
want to eat a bare end. Um,
it's, I couldn't do it anyway.
I would cancel substand updates.
We're trying to figure out another
day to do it, but I'm like,
let's kill something that I can eat. Black
bear or grizzly bear has a blackberry.
You can, you can eat oily. Mean
taste like shit though, right?
You say it's really good. It's oil.
Really. What does that mean? Oily mean?
They say it's a very thick,
that's what I call Mike and
I could imagine going gay
bear meeting with rate ray
is gay bear hunting. Thank
you. Let's find some barriers.
You find matching jacket.
You got your hunting gear.
You're going to have been like the city.
You're like, what are we doing, dude,
this guy's dressed like Bob Seger.
Let's take them down. Why do you smell?
What do you smell like? Colona why
are you wearing eyeliner and why am I,
why am I second your Dick Randy couture's,
the manliest man ever,
and she's all in the hunting with
bows and running through the woods.
Who's doing the Eco Challenge? When he
stopped fighting for awhile, you know,
which is running through the
fucking forest, the Pacific coast.
He doesn't need it. He doesn't need
a bow and Arrow or anything else.
He just does it and he just runs
a bad motherfucker, but he's a,
he's a big hunter. He loved hunting,
so he's going to take me somewhere.
We're going to go a, there's a hunting TV
show to do it with whenever I'm around.
I've been around Randy couture
couple times and um, and I,
whenever I'm around a guy like that,
I always feel a combination
of just awe and just,
I feel a little bad about myself. Well
I always feel like Jesus, you know,
I always say when people say,
why don't you [inaudible] movement
first of all because I don't want to.
And two cause I'm old and then
in black and brown eco tours,
five years older than me, five
years. Yeah. It don't be a pussy.
Joe has been it never been combat athletes
into their late forties before ever.
Never. You never saw, he
never saw a 48 year old guy.
Combination of a lot of things.
A lot of it's genetics too cause the guys
never injured, which is crazy. You know,
you, you think about all of these
different types of cancer, the camps,
sports science did a thing where he's
able to take the video like is vo Max as
much higher?
Like he's able to assimilate oxygen
and it was mussels much better than,
than most people.
Well makes sense.
He's a lifelong athlete and he was
always known. Even in the early,
early days of competing.
I've just breaking guys wills and that's
what he did to Vito Belfort as it's
imposed his will on Vitorin torn,
broken.
Well that's fucking veto for a long
time. He's relentless. He keeps you.
I'll go for the double leg on a
single lake then I, you know, then the
beat you up against the case to this was
this Machita fight in Toronto's could.
Very interesting because uh,
he,
he really firmly believes that
Machida is fights on the outside,
but you can grab a hold of them
and when you grab a hold of them,
Randy thinks he's just going to pin it
up against the cage and beat the shit out
of. Randy couture is fighting,
fighting the Cheetah Brown.
Meanwhile he's doing like the
expendables too. He's doing movies.
He's a crazy fuck dude.
And he's trying to get hunting trips and
Carl's called caliber like, Whoa, dude,
I'm such a girl.
It's good to be around those guys.
It's good to know that there's levels of,
of manliness out there.
It's good to know.
That's why sports petition young man are
very important because it teaches you
how tough you are not I've
talked to knock off you are,
but also how the top of you're not and
you need to know both and you've got to
know what other people
are willing to go through.
The kind of pain that some
people willing to go through.
You got to watch a strength thing, a real
live strength and conditioning program.
You tell him you want to
be an MMA fighter. Okay, go
to the gym with Sean Sherk.
Just watch him do that one starts. If
I watch him fucking, I don't need to,
cause I was 17 and I went to Dan Gables
and tense of wrestling camp with the
Hawkeyes and I,
and I remember limping for two weeks.
I limped wake you up at
five in the morning and you
run sprints for an hour and
then you do live wrestling.
And I, that's what,
that's why I didn't want to
wrestle in college cause I went,
if this is college athletics,
I don't want to do it.
And what happened was I'd smell a mat
and I'd get my back would start to hurt.
I got a psychosomatic injury. All right.
I bought, it was like, don't do that.
I limped I the only time in my life I
kept looking at my plane ticket and I was
going to fake an injury
so I could go home.
High school wrestling and
making a fucking man out of you.
I'll tell you though is that can't down
[inaudible] because you had to graduate
and like a third of the camp of dropout
and his intense and and literally they
closed down I believe the next
year or the year after that. Well,
they also were really encouraging people
to lose a tremendous amount of weight,
which was terrifying and really
fucking terrible. You're young body,
you know when you're 1415 years old,
you're in high school and your coaching,
you're already lean and they're telling
you to lose 10 pounds of water and
dehydration. You had to wrestle that day
too. It's not like the UFC. I did it too.
It was awesome. I did it for talking
about no tournaments too. It's terrible.
My friend did it his whole
high school career and he,
he's like really short where everyone
else's family is tall. He's five,
six and everyone else in his family sucks.
Six foot,
six foot two starving herself.
He starved himself all
through high school through,
through every fucking season
cause worse man. And he went to,
in the off season he went to camps and
like he was like really trying to make it
as a wrestler.
Boxers don't lose as much weight.
I do that cause they got to go 12 rounds.
You also have to take head blows.
It's much more dangerous when
you take the highest blows. Yeah.
That's when people get really
real serious brain damage.
Like Gerald McClellan is a perfect
example of that. He's a guy used to be,
you lose a lot of weight to
make his division. I think
he was light heavyweight.
He used to,
he was,
was a big guy and he would dehydrate
himself really bad and he didn't go about
it the right way.
And I don't know if they used Ivs back
in those days to rehydrate and now
they're pretty sophisticated about it.
They always give guys bags of Ivy,
like some guys will take six
seven eight bags. Oh really? Yeah.
They have to rehydrate and they pissed
like crazy and, but they feel much better,
much quicker as you gain a tremendous
amount of weight and like 24 hour period.
Like there's a guy glaze
and t bow fights in the UFC.
I don't know how he loses the weight.
I don't know what he does,
but this mother fucker fights at one 55
and he looks like he's like one 90 he's
fucking, you watch like a, it's
like, uh, what's the guy's name? Um,
uh, Anthony Johnson.
He walks, he's she 50.
I did wonder. He was, he was fine
with one 70 again when I was,
I was doing a movie with them in
Pittsburgh and he walked around with these
shoulders. I was like, this dude. And
he's too, I said, how much do you weigh?
It goes to 50 and I go, how are we going
to get out of the one 70? He's like,
I'll make no problem. He's got
it down to a science. I was like,
I don't know how the fuck, he's
enormous bones. He's a super athlete.
That guy is, that's powerful. Standing
around you feel like just such a wimp.
And he's an interesting guy
too because he's a wrestler,
but he's really been working
primarily on his striking, you know,
and he's knocking a lot of guys out.
That was a big victory for cost
check and crosscheck beat him.
I think a lot of that guy's
problem is that he, he has, uh,
he gets really depleted
making that one 70.
I think he'd be better served and one
85 I think a lot of guys would call.
I think a lot of guys lose too much weight
and I think over the long course of a
career, it's very dangerous.
Can I ask you that? Healthy,
I don't know if you're allowed to say,
but is there going to be a GSP Anderson
Silva fight? They want to do that,
but what GSP has to get through Jake
shields, which has no fucking cakewalk.
Jake shields is dangerous as fuck and he's
a winner and his Jujitsu is top notch.
Jake, Jake shields can
submit anybody. Sure,
but did GSP has proved that he is still
far and away these a bad motherfucker.
No doubt about it.
But you can't discount Jake shields
who GSPs never fought Jake shields.
I'm telling you, Jen shields,
look, he might be at GSP,
might be able to keep the fun
in his feet and if he does,
GSP is more than likely gonna
be far better on his feet.
He's got way better striking. We put
her hands were better kicks and Jake,
Jake is just all about
closing the distance,
getting a hold of you and drag you to the
ground. And if he can't do that, yeah,
he's in some trouble. He's going to
get boxed up. But if he can do that,
it becomes very interesting.
It becomes very interesting because
Jake shields has competed at the very
highest levels of the game in
grappling and submitted guys. In fact,
in Abu Dhabi that submitted GSP, his
level of Jujitsu is quite a bit higher.
But, but George is so
smart and he so defensively
intelligent and he's never been
submitted in them and they had before.
So at least not as also
sells a punching in the face.
Yeah and elbow and you any strong as fuck.
Fucking his wrestling is
outstanding to yeah, they say,
I've talked to guys who trained with
them and they say that he's just,
he's really, really
strong, got super humble,
he's got great strength and he's also
like really smart and he does things
correctly and he's like super driven.
Like I told you,
we worked on that turning side kick thing.
He talked to me afterwards like Joe at
practice did that thousand time I was on
this set. They were like, this
guy's crazy and kicking the bag.
I'm telling you man, I'm going to get
it. Like he was like obsessed with it.
Like ever. You show
him a technique, he'll,
he'll go over and go over
and next thing you do it,
he'll probably be doing it
better than you who taught him.
You know it's funny about that.
It's like that you see these people who
are great and they do these things and
you think it's magic. They just work than
repetitions, obsession and repetition.
And you know,
the same desire that gets you far in life
with that can also fuck you up if you
get addicted to everquest. You know,
it's the same sort of obsession. Could,
can wind you up in a ditch if it becomes
something that's not productive for me.
I have done, I know you're probably the
same way. I have to manage my addictions.
I have to like,
be real careful to keep an eye on.
Is that intense as you are that way?
You've always been really,
really obsessive. Well, it's a
problem. It's like, it's, it's,
it's not even a discipline. It's more
of a obsession. I'm disciplined, Kinda,
I mean, I get things done, I'm
disciplined, but I really am as driven.
There's a big difference
if I find something out,
like I'm not good at doing things
I don't want to do, you know,
like I'm not good at
taking out the garbage.
I'm not good at remembering to do
errands things and I'm supposed to do,
I'm not good at. But if there's
something I'm excited about it.
There's something that's uh,
that's uh, motivated about.
Then I become obsessed with it
and then I'll become driven to,
to get good at whatever
the fuck this thing is.
So it's not even like a discipline thing.
It's almost like fun.
I just know how to turn on the
crazy switch. Yeah, you're really,
really good at that,
but you got to manage that shit man.
There's a lot of people that don't and
they get into gambling and then they
become fucking crazy with
blackjack or poker or
I've always been really grateful that I
didn't have the kind of wiring that was
predisposed to the kind of negative
obsessions like that. Well,
you're self deprecating enough to the
point where you don't have to constantly
be the best guy in the
room. You know, you don't,
you can have a good time no matter what.
Some guys enjoyed my friends' successes.
I've always thought, I've always found
it more inspiring than threatening.
I never,
I just think it's like intelligence.
It's like trying to
compartmentalize anything, you know?
Well that's why you're a healthy do to,
that's where you got funded.
But it's like when I bought it, but it's
like courage. You know? Some people say,
well, I'm a coward. Well you're a coward.
Maybe you wouldn't get up
on stage and do stand up,
but you'd fight six guys in a
bar and intelligence or talent.
It's all the same stuff.
You're good at. You know?
Some people you just have to find
what you're good at. This shit.
What's your role?
It might be to support talented people.
It might be to be the one on stage.
It might be the one who comes up with
a microphone that you, that you use it.
There's club, ours, there's an managers,
there's agents, there's comics.
If you have children or stick.
Your job is to try to nudge that child
in the direction of what he's supposed to
do anyway, whatever his primal impulses
are, you know, and you contemplate,
I mean you, you have kids now. Are you
actively thinking about that? Are Your,
your daughters?
My daughter and when I tried to do
with my daughter is provide two things.
One is love, unconditional
love, so she's not messed up.
But I also believe that a large part
of my job is to stand out of the way,
not to be a suppressive,
overwhelming personality for her.
I don't want to be too
much of an influence.
And the reason I don't want
is I want her to ultimately,
I think a great deal comes from having
to be independent and also feeling free
enough and not ashamed of
whatever it is you are.
And so much of my childhood
and is now nobody's fault.
But so much of my childhood
is when I think back on it,
even my young adult eight
years is fill full of kind of.
But what I would describe as shame, I mean
certainly as confusion, but also shame,
just also this God,
I feel so different than most people.
I'm a fuck up and I've got to get my
shit together. Well, no, I didn't.
I actually had to just go deeper into
that. And so you know, to be a performer,
yes. But if you are a car salesman, yeah,
you would have had a problem. Sure. But,
but I'm saying, yeah. You know
what I mean? It's like we were,
we're lucky that this avenue exists.
Absolutely.
I'm just saying you've got to find
whatever you're having new ones.
And I think that, you know, people
say, well everybody has a path.
I don't know about that. But your job
as a young adult as a child is to tiny.
Everybody could have a path. It's not
that everybody does that. Everybody.
Could you also,
you said something really profound,
I've been thinking about a lot lately.
I thought it was really cool.
You said it's one thing to
be really accomplished and
you've accomplished things.
You be can go through all this stuff but,
but the one thing you said that you're
the most proud of is accomplishing your
peace of mind. And that is a very
separate, separate endeavor from,
from trying to make money and
trying to make a name for yourself.
Trying to be significant,
trying to be original, but that,
but actually getting to a point where
you have peace of mind I think is equally
as important as any more
important than anything it is. Um,
I'm happier now than I've ever
been at any point in my life.
And I'm also nicer to people now than
at any point ever in my own life.
And more conscious about
like biological maintenance,
making sure our workout on a regular
basis, making sure I'm healthy,
all those things together with my luck,
figure it out anyway.
Changed in some ways your personality in
a way. I mean you, you've changed, you've,
you've actually made fundamental
changes in how you relate to other human
beings. I've seen that in you. A
lot of that is psychedelics and uh,
and the tank Lieutenant Authority. It's
a combination of the tank recently. Yeah,
it was awesome.
Tell me about this.
I end with this because we've been
talking for a long time, but tell me,
tell me what your experience
was like. I uh, I got into the,
to the salt water and it was really dark
and I just found people don't know this
is a sensory deprivation tank.
We're talking about it. Yeah.
And I thought two things.
I thought I was going to go restless and
I thought the other thing I was going
to get cold and then I thought I was
going to sink and art and in fact,
um, I started to just focus
on my breath and sort of,
it was very easy for me to kind
of disappear for real. And um,
I think I stayed in there for two hours,
but I could have stayed in there way
longer, way longer. People say, you know,
you know, you, he said, I think the guy
said, you know, 15 minutes in or you know,
or you might be in there for an hour,
but it might be hard for me. I could've,
I could've just stayed in there.
It's amazing environment, isn't it?
You need to get one of those. I think we
all need that. When you live in the area,
she can go, yeah, and you can go to
that place all the time. But man,
having one of your houses, this shit,
how often you change that water,
you don't have to,
you don't have to.
It's only me that goes in it and there's
800 pounds of salt and nothing can live
in there. That's amazing. Yeah.
It's like it's, it's so dense. Yeah,
it is is just like that.
It's the most valuable program
ever or the valuable tool ever for
reprogramming your mind,
for looking at yourself and then in a
truly objective way and to be tethered,
untethered rather from your life,
untethered from your,
your personal experiences
and able to look at them.
Literally when you're inside that tank,
it feels like you're not there.
It feels like you time has essentially
stopped. You're not getting any input.
It might be going on without you
all rambling free in the world,
but in your life,
your,
your life is all about how you relate
to everything that you see in your
environment, so having a chance
to be out of your environment,
the only opportunity that
you have in the world,
that's the only environment
on the planet like that.
When you can go and separate yourself
literally from your life and watch
yourself if you don't know
what we're talking about.
We're talking about a
sensory deprivation tank,
which was created by a psychedelic
pioneer from the fifties named John Lilly,
who's this brilliant scientist
who was incredibly eccentric.
And one of the things he wanted to figure
out was how to detach himself from his
physical inputs,
inputs of sound and feeling and seeing
things and how to figure out how to get
the mind literally away
from any input to the body.
He realized that life is very distracting
and that you know conversations that
you're having. If there's a bus
driving by right next to you,
it's hard to have that conversation.
The buses distracting things,
input is distracting and
when you were in the tank,
you are literally dealing with no input.
You have no hearing because your ears
are under water and it's a big heavy door
that's shut and it's pretty soundproof.
You have no seen cause you're in total
blackness. You total complete darkness,
you know,
feel anything because the water's the
same temperature as your skin and the
water has 800 pounds of salt in it.
So you completely buoyant and it's
the most amazing environment, man.
It goes into that. Really that was that,
that I think therefore I am right. Um,
they carts so,
but,
but that's always been disputed in the
sense that because you can imagine it
doesn't mean indeed that it's
e that it's actually there.
Well then the question is
what is the imagination?
This is the real question is what is
the imagination and our thoughts really
nonlocal when all you really,
are you really just a biological antenna
that like picks up entropy in the air
that picks up creativity and
ideas and things. And these are,
these are literally like woven into
the fabric of time all around us.
You know what that great mathematician
and won the fields medal said, right?
And he refuses to fields metal, which
is $1 million prize, I believe in.
It's like the Nobel prize for mathematics.
They couldn't find them Fadiman
Siberia year later. And he goes,
why are you giving me the price that
you should be given the equation for us?
I just,
I just have antenna.
I'm wired a certain way and I
was able to channel the answer.
I think it was a 350 page answer they've
been looking at. They, they, even the,
even the problem had been conjectured
in like 1806 and they were trying to,
the actual problem. Then he came up with
the answer and all these mathematician,
like this guy actually figured it out
after 300 years and he's just incredible
really? And he goes, yeah,
yeah, but what, what are you,
you're giving the prize to the,
to the radio.
You should be giving it to the music.
They all say that. Every artist says that.
Every great writer says that they tune
into the, you know, it's, it's a tough,
it makes me believe in any kind of God
or whatever you want to call it. A,
you know, a higher benevolent force of
some kind or at least something of beauty.
I don't know. What was my point
that that, that, that we, we,
what is imagination? Well, thank you.
This is my point was the
idea of imagination is very
strange because you have
this idea, you have this, this thing
that comes in your mind. Wait a minute,
if I do this and combine it with
that, Holy Shit. I just reinvent.
I just made a new invention
is going to be quick.
This is going to revolutionize what you've
done is with this thing in the ether.
You have pulled it out of that and now
it manifests itself in a physical form
and alters human life.
It's good. It changes life.
Like all the things that
people have invented,
they had to initially think
up whether it's the car,
whether it's computers or this had
to be a thought in someone's mind,
a creative idea or a conglomeration of
other ideas that have existed before.
That's a common story thing
and they combine it and make
some new creative thing,
but whatever the imagination is,
it eventually manifests
itself as an actual thing.
So we don't look at that for
some of those other ones.
Frivolous imagination is also way
more important than what you consider
intelligence are amassing information.
Imagination is what moves history forward.
It Gutenberg, Innovation, Gutenberg, when
he came up with a printing press, uh,
even Freud when he came up with a
concept that you could figure out how the
human mind works. Einstein's
theory of relativity, Newton's
a, you know, calculus,
these guys who were these seminal
thinkers who came up with,
with even Karl Marx for that matter,
I'm not a communist,
but these guys who came up with these
sort of seminal concepts of, you know,
how to restructure our society,
how to restructure our biology,
how to restructure our minds,
how to look at our minds,
all those things from the man's
imagination and it and it and it,
and we leaped forward in some ways.
Not In a good way. In some ways.
We came up with the atomic bomb.
Well, yeah, I mean, but the atom,
but it's all the same thing, right?
It's all people and you know,
whatever branch of study that they choose
to pursue, you know, they, they, they,
they create things.
That's right.
You know and it becomes
an actual physical thing,
but what is the imagination
that's making that happen?
Is it like a life form and was the point?
Yeah,
and also what's the
point that the diagram,
the the map of the universe
and we're supposed to follow,
he brought this podcast full
circle because we started
with that question and we
end with that question. Who knows?
Have imagination kids. This is,
this is our message folks. Just be fucking
nice to people. If we all were cool,
if everybody was like the
people in this room right now,
if the whole world was made up of us
and we just ran into us everywhere,
I mean I'm not, that's so
egocentric and ridiculous to say,
but the mindset of what I'm talking about,
just be cool to people. Just be nice.
You know what the problem is? Sometimes
competition is the problem. Not only that,
sometimes she always has an idea that
they think is better for you. So example,
the board, the boat was that
certain people in Kansas say,
let's start teaching intelligent design
and not evolution and we're going to
teach your child that because it's better
for his soul and all of a sudden you
go, wait a minute, you're
trying to be nice to me,
but I don't want that kind of Nice.
Yeah, that's the wrong kind of Nice.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Talking about people not
fucking with other people.
Don't watch all of the people worry about
yourself. There's just so many of us.
There's so many of us.
It's hard to get this all across,
but I firmly believe that we right
now are more advanced, more in tune,
more tuned in than any other generation
has ever been before and a lot of is
because of stuff like this.
A lot of it is because of the podcast,
Internet things. You can read the, the
access to information, all these things.
We were communicating in a
way with Twitter and with
Facebook and that no one's
ever done before.
I think we're connected the
way we've never been before
in real time. Yeah. This,
these things that we are, we're
all pushing together. It's a,
it's a fascinating time and I think human
beings culturally are evolving at a,
at a,
an incredible race at an incredible pace
rather exponential technology certainly
to say. Yeah, that's still the nuttiest
thing about all this 2012 nonsense.
It says fuck everything's
pointing towards that being real.
Everything's pointing towards all these
fucking events happening in people
changing and technology
accelerated an incredible pace.
When we talked about earlier about the
center of every galaxy being a black hole
that we were talking about that,
well that's what they're trying to do
with the large hadron collider there
making black holes.
So the center of every galaxy is a black
hole and inside that black hole is a
universe and then they're making universes
like what does the breaks out Matt,
we are butterflies and we are on our way
to being the next thing you know there
was a caterpillar that became a butterfly
and that is the human. Did you want to,
if you want an actually
great lecture on that,
it's called Homo ever lewdness and it's
by one Enrique is it could have ted.com
and won and rake us.
We'll take you through a lecture called
Homo have alluded to and he talks about
how we're coming out with,
for example,
eyes well that that right
now can see shadow and light,
but they're going to pretty much pursuing
to be able to see underwater and in
the dark for a mile away and eventually
or is that can see a mile away.
All that stuff and we're going to become,
we're going to start to become machine
part machine as we come up with bio
compatible components,
wave facet and we're going to ever evolve
into the whatever else we're supposed
to buy a lot. I know people
already that have artificial hips.
I know a couple of people and dude,
my hip starts clicking now
your hips are fucked up.
My hip on this side really hurts
sometimes when I move the wrong.
Try being a top every now and then,
hey
gang gave you the greatest. Thank you
very much for being on the podcast. Again,
always the most fascinating,
intriguing in depth conversations.
Head spinning shit.
I don't want to have to go back and
review it because there was a lot of stuff
that we talked about that I'm like,
wow, I really need to consider this.
And I apologize for any a and accuracies.
It is the,
we just start talking and we just
start all the way. Always an honor.
Always a pleasure Brian. And people
can follow Brian on, on Twitter.
It's B R, y a n, C A, l, l, e,
n following him on Twitter and follow
red band. Oh, by the way, and by the way,
I'm doing the palms. Uh, I'm doing
the palm standup this weekend. Oh,
this weekend in Vegas. In Vegas.
Seriously. He's one of the funniest,
most unique human beings on the planet.
He's responsible for three,
one of the three funniest things
I've ever seen in my life. The, the,
the gay Jujitsu sketch that you in a
hotel room and Vegas between that and Joey
Diaz showing his balls and
Duncan trussell's new video.
Duncan Trussell though.
Good, isn't it? So good seeing
it. Well, it's junk. And
then his girlfriend Natasha,
the no one's seen it yet. You can
only watch it on his computer. Yeah,
it hasn't been released yet.
When it does get released.
I made a video on my iPhone talking
about how great it is and like you people
are going to freak. It's going to get
like a million hits in the first week.
It's fucking great. Fucking
hilarious. Is this is, this is his,
his thing. His is his
greatest accomplishment. It's,
yeah, it's pretty genius.
It's Dunkin in a nutshell and Natasha
in a nutshell together. All right.
This weekend Gotham sold out next weekend.
There's a few tickets left for
the Moore Theater in Seattle,
but that's going fast too.
And then we're in Portland the week
after that add a helium in Portland. Um,
it's all on Joe rogan.net and this
Wednesday we are at Sal's comedy whole.
Got some funny fucking people and
they're just on Steve Run is easy.
Freddy Lockhart, Doug Fence
and, and Bret Ernst. Yeah.
It's a good lineup ladies and gentlemen.
So you don't want to miss that shit.
And South County Hall is only like 80
or 90 people and we do it pretty much
every Wednesday,
every Wednesday and went to town.
We fuck around and we come
up with new material. We have
fun. We, you know, it's a,
it's a great environment.
You're gonna see a lot of cool comics.
It's like a VIP show right now.
Like these 80 people or getting a crazy
show me Sarah Silverman did it last week
or Doug Benson. Slash. Ginger. You know,
we always have like top notch guys come
down and fuck around and it's like a
really good environment.
It's a really fun putting,
are you doing anything Wednesday w nine
columns on the show. Lesions does that.
I'll actually be in a, I have to do
breath at eight o'clock. Fuck. Why?
What time I have you done? What
time? What time is your set?
Are you closing your closing? I'm closing.
Okay. You won't be done time. All right.
Yeah, we started at nine
or well, any Wednesday.
We do it every Wednesday at eight o'clock.
8:00 PM sales company that I want to
come. Yeah, you're coming. You're coming.
It's the greatest.
It's the new hangout.
It's the new greatest place
to fuck around for standup.
Everyone super supportive. Everyone that
works there. Cools Fox sound is an ace.
He's just so super warm, friendly, calm
house. He's got a new place. It's on.
It's on Melrose now. Oh Great. I'd love
to be a real small place. The Ip part,
our vi or VIP service now or, uh, what
does that mean? Valet service now?
Starting this Wednesday. Really? Yeah,
so because the parking was a little,
we have some foreign dude your keys and
make sure he doesn't steal your weed.
Yeah, I'm all right man. Listen,
bitches. You know, we love you. And uh,
we will see you tomorrow with Joey.
Coco Diaz.
None other than the other one or
the other. Funniest human beings.
Funny experiences. You know what the fuck
I'm talking about bitches. All right.
I love you guys winning.
Yes.